So I booted up today and here's what I noticed.
Okay.
You know, you just start talking and you hope an interesting thought comes into your head.
That's where I find myself right now.
So I booted up.
What I noticed was.
You thought talking about booting up was going to get you going?
Yeah, it was just going to trigger something for the cold open.
所以我今天启动了，这就是我注意到的。好吧。你知道，你刚开始说话，就希望脑子里能蹦出个有趣的念头。我现在就是这种状态。所以我启动了。我注意到的是。你以为谈论启动就能让你进入状态？是啊，这只是为了给开场白找个引子。
Anything ever funny ever happened for you guys when you boot up?
Look at this.
Oh, Sean's wearing a boot.
Oh, he's still wearing his walking boot.
Now we're into a free cell association, and it's improv and yes and and to an all-new smart list.
Smart.
I apologize for picking my teeth.
I just got through a bunch of really leafy vegetables.
你们在启动的时候有没有发生过什么有趣的事？看这个。哦，肖恩穿着靴子。哦，他还在穿他的助行靴。现在我们进入了自由联想，这是即兴表演，还有“是的，而且”到全新的智能列表。智能。我为剔牙道歉。我刚吃了一堆叶菜。
Okay.
So I might have to excuse myself mid-record here.
You think?
Well, I mean, I don't know.
Well, no.
Why don't you get some floss?
I've got the little pick right here.
I apologize.
好吧。所以我可能得在录制中途告退一下。你觉得呢？嗯，我是说，我不知道。好吧，不。你为什么不去用牙线呢？我这儿有小牙签。我道歉。
You're having to watch.
You and whoever the surprise guest is, I apologize.
You can't bear it until after?
No, if I have something stuck between my teeth, everything stops.
Yeah, yeah, I'm kind of the same way.
I can't. It's like a bee is stuck in my car.
I got to pull over.
You've got a B in your butt.
你得看着。你和那位惊喜嘉宾，我道歉。你不能等到结束后吗？不，如果我牙缝里卡了东西，一切都会停下来。是啊，是啊，我也一样。我受不了。就像蜜蜂卡在我的车里一样。我得靠边停车。你屁股里有只蜜蜂。
Yeah, you've got to be in your butt.
Hey, there's a good saying.
You should start that.
You got to be in your bottom.
J.B. Now, how's your new setup?
J.B.'s in New York now.
How's your setup?
Pretty good?
是啊，你屁股里有只蜜蜂。嘿，这是句好话。你应该开个头。你屁股里有只蜜蜂。J.B. 现在，你的新布置怎么样？J.B. 现在在纽约。你的布置怎么样？还不错吧？
It's good.
I'm just, I'm in the hotel for a week, and then I get the keys on Friday.
So then I'll go over to the,
a partamante and um and you'll be there for three four months yes yeah wow isn't it wild and i just
got back oh wow i know why i should be playing i should be staying at your place yeah by the way
why don't you oh too late you dick you could a real safe invite now that i'm obligated to a
fucking long-term lease you know you could have done you done that but it was it's been too small for you
i'm gonna be there i'm gonna be there i'm gonna be there i'm gonna be there well i don't be there
挺好的。我只是，我在酒店住一周，然后周五拿到钥匙。然后我就去那个公寓，嗯，你会待在那里三四个月，是的，哇，这不是很疯狂吗？我刚回来，哦，哇，我知道为什么我应该住，我应该住在你那儿，是啊，顺便问一下，你为什么不，哦，太晚了，你这个混蛋，你现在才发出真正的邀请，我已经签了该死的长期租约了，你知道，你本可以那样做的，但那对你来说太小了，我要去那儿，我要去那儿，我要去那儿，我要去那儿，好吧，我不会去那儿。
Because life.
Because they're right.
Laf.
Yeah, maybe, yeah, so I guess that's why I couldn't stay at your place.
You've got a nice new fancy spot here, don't you?
I don't have, I don't have keys yet.
Why?
Because you're making it fancy here?
因为生活。因为他们是对的。生活。是啊，也许吧，是啊，所以我猜这就是为什么我不能住在你那儿。你这儿有个不错的新时髦地方，不是吗？我还没有，我还没有钥匙。为什么？因为你正在这儿把它弄得时髦点？
You're in the middle of making it fancy here?
No, no, no, no.
It's a long, it's complicated.
But I'm very excited.
We're excited for you.
I'm super jealous.
You know how long I've wanted to live here.
I know.
你正在把它弄得时髦的过程中？不，不，不，不。这很长，很复杂。但我很兴奋。我们为你感到兴奋。我超级嫉妒。你知道我有多想住在这里吗。我知道。
Why don't you just get a little tiny something?
Your second?
How many times have you had a place in Manhattan, Will?
Oh, God.
Like a place, not like a hotel, but a...
Yeah, you and Amy used to live there.
I lived there for over 20 years, full-time.
我知道。你为什么不弄个小一点的地方呢？你的第二个？威尔，你在曼哈顿住过多少次了？哦，天哪。像个住处，不是像酒店，而是……是啊，你和艾米以前住在那儿。我全职在那里住了20多年。
Yeah, but that was just one spot, right?
I mean, different spots have you had here.
Different, oh, my God, countless.
I had so many.
You have more or less than a dozen apartments.
How many do you count them?
More or less than a dozen apartments in Manhattan.
Probably around a dozen.
是啊，但那只是一个地方，对吧？我是说，你在不同地方住过。不同的，哦，天哪，数不清。我有很多。你住过十二个以上的公寓吗？你怎么算的？在曼哈顿住过十二个左右的公寓。大概十二个左右吧。
Oh, really?
Yeah, something like that.
Close to it.
That sounds like I'm so jealous.
You, Sean?
In New York?
Sean is your first?
Is that your first?
哦，真的吗？是啊，差不多。接近那个数。听起来我好嫉妒。你呢，肖恩？在纽约？肖恩是你的第一个？那是你的第一个吗？
It's the first place I've owned, yeah, for now six years.
But back in the day, used to move around a lot.
You know, like you'd live with roommates for a year and then somebody would bail and so you'd have to move cross town.
I used to be able to move in a taxi, one taxi cab ride.
Just a couple duffel bags, for real.
And stuff like a mattress, like a futon mattress in the trunk and then like go cross town.
And then I move back cross town and whatever.
Oh, this is sad.
这是我拥有的第一个地方，是的，已经六年了。但以前，我经常搬家。你知道，就像你和室友住一年，然后有人退出，你就得搬到城另一头。我以前能用出租车搬家，一辆出租车就够了。就几个行李袋，真的。还有像后备箱里的蒲团床垫之类的东西，然后搬到城另一头。然后我又搬回城另一头之类的。哦，这太可悲了。
Those are sad moves.
I think fondly back, I used to live on 21st Street for years,
and I remember having, I lived in this, basically a studio,
this is such a boring story, but I'm going to do it anyway,
and fold up Futon mattress, I didn't even have the frame,
so in the day I'd roll it up in the corner.
Just a couch.
On the floor, just a swollen yoga mat.
那些搬家很可悲。我深情地回想，我以前在21街住了好几年，我记得我住在这个，基本上是个单间，这故事太无聊了，但我还是要讲，还有一个折叠蒲团床垫，我甚至没有床架，所以白天我就把它卷在角落里。就像个沙发。在地板上，就像个肿胀的瑜伽垫。
Yeah, and then I'd have that, and then I had like two pairs of jeans
and two T-shirts and whatever.
It was so, it was so simple.
Yeah.
And there was just, there was nothing, there was nothing.
It was just, I gotta say it was incredible.
But isn't, isn't one of the greatest things about getting older
is you don't move around like that.
是啊，然后我就有那个，然后我有两条牛仔裤和两件T恤之类的。太，太简单了。是啊。而且什么都没有，什么都没有。我得说这太不可思议了。但变老最棒的事情之一不就是你不会那样搬来搬去吗。
Like that's, it's just exhaust.
You don't realize when you're younger, how exhausting is to keep moving and moving and moving.
I still, I still, I still remember.
Well, you also become attached to more, you get attached to more stuff as you get older too, right?
Or do you get rid of it?
You're like, fuck, where's all this stuff?
Hey, Sean, is it, is that a new placement for the SAG Award, of which I bet you have many?
Yeah, we don't need to see your fucking awards in the background.
就像那样，太累人了。你年轻时没意识到，一直搬来搬去有多累。我仍然，我仍然，我仍然记得。嗯，你也变得更依恋东西了，随着年龄增长你也变得更依恋东西了，对吧？还是你把它扔了？你会想，该死，这些东西都在哪儿？嘿，肖恩，那是演员工会奖的新位置吗，我敢打赌你有很多？是啊，我们不需要看你背景里那些该死的奖项。
Nobody counts four SAG Awards.
Oh, shit.
Why would you count that?
Yeah, but that's a new spot right over your shoulder.
No, I don't know who put it there.
I swear I don't.
Okay, Scottie.
I'm taking it out after.
没人会数四个演员工会奖。哦，该死。你为什么要数那个？是啊，但那是你肩膀上方的一个新位置。不，我不知道是谁把它放在那儿的。我发誓我不知道。好吧，斯科蒂。我待会儿把它拿走。
Well, let's find out with a mystery of who put the SAG Award in frame.
But have you noticed that people do that on their Zooms?
They put the awards in the background.
Why is that?
I'm more, I'm still bothered about that TV behind you,
because it never gets viewed because it's in the worst.
Well, sometimes, sometimes if...
Never.
好吧，让我们找出是谁把演员工会奖放在镜头里的谜团。但你有没有注意到人们在Zoom上会那样做？他们把奖项放在背景里。为什么会这样？我更，我仍然对你身后的那台电视感到困扰，因为它从来没被看过，因为它在最糟糕的位置。嗯，有时，有时如果……从来没有。
Well, no, sometimes if...
This is my office, and so...
I know where it is.
Yeah, if we could see the fax machine.
Oh, God, he's really knocking down big deals over there.
But it's just the placement of it is so locked in.
And then the seating on the other side of your desk is so far away to watch that.
I know. No, it's not that far.
嗯，不，有时如果……这是我的办公室，所以……我知道它在哪儿。是啊，如果我们能看到传真机就好了。哦，天哪，他真的在那儿谈成大生意了。但它的位置太固定了。而且你桌子另一边的座位离那儿太远了，没法看。我知道。不，没那么远。
Anyway, when Scotty's got something going on, I come in here and I'll watch.
I don't need to.
to explain myself to you.
Okay, here we go.
Ready?
Watch this.
Sure.
My guest today is smarter
总之，当斯科蒂有事的时候，我会进来看看。我不需要向你解释我自己。好吧，我们开始吧。准备好了吗？看这个。当然。我今天的嘉宾比我们所有人加起来都聪明，而且几乎只有我们一半大。他大学开始时是医学预科化学专业，因为他受到了《实习医生格蕾》中吴珊卓角色的启发……这是《天才医生杜吉》吗？《实习医生格蕾》。
than all of us combined
and practically half our age.
He started college
as a pre-med chemistry major
because he was inspired by Sandra O's character
on crazy...
Is this Dugie House?
Crazy Anatomy.
他出生在澳大利亚，搬到了魁北克，九岁时搬到了科罗拉多。后来，他搬到了纽约，找了一份平面设计工作来支付账单，同时做深夜即兴表演，最终走进30号大楼并预订了《周六夜现场》，给了他七季和五次艾美奖提名。
He was born in Australia,
moved to Quebec, then to Colorado when he was nine.
Later, he moved to New York,
got a graphic design job to pay the bills
while doing late-night improv
and eventually walking.
into 30 Rock and booked Saturday Night Live,
giving him seven seasons and five Emmy nominations.
这是搞笑、令人愉快的杨伯文。哦，天哪。是杜吉。怎么了，伙计？是天才医生杜吉。我从没看过。我从没看过那个节目。你太年轻了。
It's a hilarious, delightful Bowen Yang.
Oh my goodness.
It's Doogie.
What's up, doggs?
It's Doogie Houser.
I've never seen it.
I've never seen that show.
You're too young.
我觉得我没看过片段。等等，伯文，你身后也有奖项。不，我，你们，我知道你们是。不，那是本·富兰克林的半身像。这是本·富兰克林。不，这是他们给我的《周六夜现场》离别礼物。化妆师，所以现在他们会对你的脸进行3D扫描。是啊，那是劳恩。
I don't think I've seen pieces of it.
Wait, Bowen's got you, you've got awards behind you too.
No, and I, you guys, I knew you guys were.
No, that's a bust of Ben Franklin.
This is Ben Franklin.
No, this is the parting gift they gave me at S&L.
The makeup guy, so now they do 3D scans of your face.
Yeah, that's Lauren.
不，他们会对你的脸进行3D扫描。是的，他是。哦，该死。没关系，但我们在那儿玩得很开心，杰森。我们得读一年该死的。我喜欢这个，顺便说一句。这有一种特殊的品质。这太像《女友星期五》了，只是你们所有人都在重叠。
No, they do 3D scans of your face.
Yes, he is.
Oh, God damn it.
It's okay, but we had a good time there, Jason.
We got to read a fucking year.
I love this, by the way.
There's a special quality to this.
It's so his Girl Friday, just you guys all overlapping.
太酷了。我们是最糟糕的采访者，我们因为总是打断对方而受到很多批评。人们会说，我希望他们闭嘴。我们说，好吧，这就是对话，对吧？人们不明白。你那边呢？你们总是重叠。还是你们一起做？
It's so cool.
We're the worst interviewers, and we get a lot of shit because we interrupt each other all the time.
People are like, I wish they'd shut up.
We're like, well, this is what a conversation is, right?
People don't get it.
What about on yours?
You guys overlap by bed all the time.
Or do you do it together?
拉斯·科尔特里塔斯。我们现在一起做。我们过去常做，过去几年我们在Zoom上做很多，但现在我们回到了空间、共享、什么的。工作室。你们真的要对我的架子进行罗夏测试，是吗？我不明白，这就是关于奖项的事情。我的大多是玻璃的，我觉得它们不如黄铜的合法。
Las Colteritas.
We do it together now.
We used to do, we would do it very much on Zoom in years past,
but now we're back to spatial, shared, whatever.
Studio.
You guys are going to really Rorschach test my shelves, aren't you?
I don't see, this is the thing about awards.
Mine are mostly glass, which I feel like are less legitimate than the brass.
什么，你的奖项？因为它们可能会碎。好吧，让我们继续。在书上。你有凯特·布什。是啊。哦，真的吗？我有个凯特·布什的东西。
What, your awards?
Because they could break.
Well, let's go.
on the books.
You got Cape Bush.
Yeah.
Oh, really?
I got a Cape Bush thing.
哦，是啊。我喜欢凯特·布什。你有什么？HomePod？那是上面的HomePod吗？这是Sonos。这是Sonos。哦，明白了。
Oh, yeah.
I like Kate Bush.
What do you got?
A home pod?
Is that a home pod up in there?
This is a Sonos.
Oh, gotcha.
那个金色的东西是什么？那个金色的东西是金球奖吗？不，这是新重新设计的学院博物馆荣誉。它过去是……我在那儿。你在那儿。你拿到它的时候我在那儿。
What's the gold one?
The gold thing is a golden globe?
No, this is the newly redesigned
Academy Museum honor.
It used to be...
I was there.
You were there.
I was there when you got it.
你拿到它的时候我在那儿。是啊。恭喜。它们过去是……谢谢。但它们过去是更小的、银色的奥斯卡雕像。现在它们，现在它是一个金色的冰淇淋蛋筒。
Yeah.
Congratulations.
They used to be...
Thank you.
But they used to be smaller,
silver Oscar statues.
And now they, now it's a gold ice cream cone.
我不明白他们为什么要改它。它是为了什么？氛围。我不知道。为了优秀，你这个笨蛋。为了在他所做的事情上表现出色。肖恩，也就是，这里有人能描述我做什么吗？我不知道你是否知道肖恩，肖恩赢了一顶银色软呢帽。
I don't understand why they changed it.
What's it for?
Vives.
I don't know.
For being excellent, you dumb ass.
For being great at what he does.
Sean, which is, can anyone here describe what I do?
I don't know if you know that Sean, Sean won a silver fedora.
是啊，看那个。很酷。为了出色地扮演印第安纳·琼斯。那太棒了。而且他扮演得非常出色。杨伯文，怎么了？是啊。跟你说话。等一下。
Yeah, look at that.
It's cool.
For excellent cosplaying of Indiana Jones.
That's excellent.
And he was excellent out of it.
Bo and Yang, what's what?
Yeah.
Talk to you. Hang on a second.
不，别对我“是啊”。我正在和杨伯文说话。哇。你怎么敢？太粗鲁了。冷静点。你只是太，抱歉。不，我想和杨伯文说一会儿话。
No, don't yeah me.
I'm fucking talking to Bo and Yang.
Wow.
How dare you?
That's so rude.
Cool it.
You just too, sorry.
No, I want to talk to Bowen Yang for a second.
我想知道你是怎么搬来搬去的，为什么，发生了什么。我们刚才在谈论搬来搬去，然后肖恩介绍你，就像乒乓球一样。是啊。到处都是。我为什么要搬来搬去？是啊。你的父母，你出生了，然后你搬到了魁北克，然后不能。
I want to know how and why you moved around and what happened.
We were just talking about moving around and then Sean introses you and it's like ping
bummed.
Yeah.
All over the place.
Why did I move around?
Yeah.
Your parents, you were born and then you moved to Quebec and then can't.
然后，我刚才说了什么？谁在澳大利亚开始的。然后你因为某种原因不得不离开那儿。魁北克，然后科罗拉多。是啊，是啊，是啊。魁北克和科罗拉多。不，哦，是，我爸爸在同一份工作上待了过去，像，308年。但他是在澳大利亚拿的博士学位。
And then, what did I just say?
Who started in Australia.
Then you had to get the hell out of there for some reason.
Quebec and then Colorado.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Quebec and Colorado.
No, oh, it was, my dad's been at the same job for the past, like, 308 years.
But he got his doctorate in Australia.
所以我和我妹妹是在布里斯班出生的。然后我们搬到了加拿大，蒙特利尔，我在那里了解了席琳·迪翁，然后我们搬到了科罗拉多，为了，你在那里了解了什么？我了解了……哦，不，我搬到了科罗拉多。我现在要惹麻烦了。在……的尾声。
So that's where my sister and I were born in Brisbane.
Then we moved to Canada, Montreal, where I learned about Celine Dion,
and then we moved to Colorado for,
And what did you learn about there?
I learned about...
Oh, no, I moved to Colorado.
I'm going to get in trouble right now.
At the tail end of...
我要惹麻烦了。我在克林顿政府的尾声，科伦拜恩和琼贝内之后搬到了科罗拉多。所以作为一个八岁的孩子，我像……整个克林顿政府都是关于尾声的。老实说，伙计们。嘿，等等，伯文，伯文，多少年……
I'm going to get in trouble.
I moved at the tail end of the Clinton administration
right after Columbine and Jean-Meney
to Colorado.
So as an eight-year-old, I'm like...
The whole Clinton administration was about tail-end.
Let's be honest, okay, guys.
Hey, wait, Bowen, Bowen, how many years...
你从魁北克搬走时多大？因为我想进入加拿大的事情，显然作为一个加拿大人。让我们进入它。是的，我很乐意。八岁。所以我歇斯底里地哭着，说，我们为什么要搬到那个地方。
How old were you then when you moved from Quebec?
Because I want to get into the Canada stuff,
obviously as a Canadian.
Let's get into it.
Yes, I would love to.
Eight years old.
So I was hysterically sobbing,
being like, why are we moving to the place
人们被杀的地方？就在琼贝内之后，他在博尔德，而且是在，就像，是在所有这些混乱之后。等等，但这很有趣。我要告诉你，威尔，因为这是，这会提示伯文，也就是，你爸爸真的是在内蒙古的一个稻草和泥屋里长大的，靠烛光自学阅读，拿到了采矿炸药的博士学位，那是什么，那是对的，然后搬过了三个国家，这太疯狂了，你可以去学校学任何东西，所以他拿到了炸东西的博士学位。
where people get killed?
It was right after Jean-Bene, who was in Boulder,
and it was after, like,
it was after all this mess.
Wait, but this is interesting.
I'm going to tell you, Willie,
because this is, and this will prompt Bowen,
which is, your dad grew up literally
是啊，在采石场之类的炸东西，是的，好吧，他喜欢它，我想他想带到哪儿就带到哪儿，当然，但当我喜欢你的解释时，我喜欢你的解释，他喜欢它，他喜欢它。
in a straw and mud hut
in Inner Mongolia,
taught himself to read by Candleight,
got a PhD in mining explosive,
what that's right
and then moved across three countries
that's crazy you can go to school for anything
so he got a doctorate in blowing
但就像那样，我想你会是，我希望有人在把炸药钥匙交给某人之前非常有资历。对。当然。是啊。是啊。
stuff up
yeah and blowing stuff up
for at quarries and such
yes well he loves it
take it anywhere he wants I guess sure
but when I love your explanation
I love your explanation he loves it
he loves it
然后你去了，当你，继续。不，你先，你先。我本来想说，这会和威尔有关，你去了，你就像，被克里斯托弗·拉夫斯震撼了，那是什么，一个喜剧节。双关语。双关语。我被震撼了。双关语。
but like that
I guess you would be I would want someone
to be very credentialed before I
hand of the keys to some explosives.
Right.
Sure.
Yeah.
是啊，真的很好。只是比尔。所以，威尔。鲁。哦，他们来了。我们。啊，他们不是。我们明白了。
And then you went to when you, go ahead.
No, you go, you go.
I was going to say, this would relate to Will, you went to, you were like, blown away by
Christopher laughs, which is what, a comedy festival.
Pun.
I was blown away.
会有像免费的街头表演者。什么？什么，杰森？杰森，杰森，我希望我懂一门语言。不，但你对文化过敏。不，但你对“他妈的”过敏。你没有这个通往“他妈的”的桥梁。我有一支烟。
Yeah, really good.
Just be rier.
So, Will.
Rue.
Oh, here they go.
We.
Ah, they're not.
We get it.
等等。我喜欢蒙特利尔。我也喜欢。蒙特利尔是一个非凡的城市。真的，真的。我是说，就像，人们说波特兰有最好的脱衣舞俱乐部。蒙特利尔有最好的脱衣舞俱乐部。而且我能，我作为一个孩子有权说这个。
There would be like free street performers.
What?
What, Jason?
Jason, Jason, I wish I knew a language.
No, but you're allergic to culture.
No, but you are allergic to tabernac.
You do not have this bridge to tabernac, chri-so.
I have a one cigarette.
你从唐人街回郊区的路上开车经过它们，你会经过脱衣舞俱乐部，它们有很棒的灯光。温哥华的芭蕾舞也很棒。别把那该死的东西拖到这儿来。不，就在机场外面，就在那儿。举起你的手臂。没人能像蒙特利尔那样做脱衣舞酒吧。
Wait.
I love Montreal.
So do I.
Montreal is a phenomenal city.
Truly, truly.
I mean, like, people say Portland has the best strip clubs.
Montreal had the best trip clubs.
and I could have, I had the authority to say this as a child.
不，老脱衣舞者，是啊。嘿？总之，所以是什么。你是因为“笑话而已”而受到启发的吗？就像，你看到的第一件事是什么？你就像，哦，天哪，我要做那个。笑声。笑声。我听到了笑声。
You drive through them on the way back from Chinatown into the suburbs,
and you would pass by the strip clubs,
and they had great lights.
Vancouver was pretty gifted for the ballet as well.
Don't you drag that shit into here.
No, Frills your arms right there, just outside the airport there.
Raise your arms.
Nobody does a peeler bar like Montreal.
会有，就像，街头表演者，他们仍然有那个。但是，就像，会有免费的街头表演，而且会是最，就像，魁北克，疯狂，古怪的东西，就像，一个哑剧演员，就像，从耳朵里拉出什么东西。就像，我不知道。这只是，就像，小丑表演加上，就像，笑话。我不知道。它只是不需要有意义，你知道吗？是啊，是啊。
No, old peelers, yeah.
Hey?
Anyway, so what were.
You were you inspired by it just for laughs?
Like, what's the first thing you saw?
You're like, oh, my God, I'm going to do that.
The laughs.
The laughs. I heard the laughs.
就是那个，然后……所以蒙特利尔是几岁到几岁？抱歉。是……不，没关系。是三到九岁。三到九岁，然后去科罗拉多。然后去科罗拉多，九到17岁。
There would be, like, street performers, and they still have that.
But, like, it would be free street performances, and it would be the most, like, Quebec,
crazy, kooky stuff, like, a mime who, like, pulls something out of his ear.
Like, I don't know.
It was just, like, clowning plus, like, jokes.
I don't know.
It just didn't have to make sense, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
17岁到现在是哪里？纽约。17岁到现在一直是纽约。哇。哇。我17岁。那是……当人们问我，你来自哪里？
It was that and then...
So Montreal was what ages to what ages?
Sorry.
It was...
No, that's okay.
It was three to nine.
Three to nine, and then to Colorado.
And then to Colorado, nine to 17.
我不知道。你不确定该说什么？我觉得如果我说……好吧，如果我说……哦，科罗拉多，然后是之前的加拿大，人们会说，当我告诉他们我在那里长大的年份时，他们会说，哦，好吧，你应该只说科罗拉多，我像，是啊，但在发育上。
And 17 to what was where?
New York.
And 17 to now has been New York.
Wow.
I'm 17.
Is that...
When people ask me, where are you from?
就像那些加拿大的岁月对我来说很重要，好吧，多少，但真的，我是说对于我们任何人，九岁之前你记得多少？不多，是啊，只是很多尖叫的轮胎，约翰尼，不是我们所有人都不得不把它抹掉，伙计，你知道我的意思吗，哦，是啊，是啊，杰克·贝茨，杰基试图学习如何在《草原小屋》的片场死去，并得到关于少一点死亡的笔记，杰克，好吗？小杰基·贝茨留着这个碗盖头。你见过照片吗？谷歌搜索杰森小时候的样子。他太他妈可爱了。是啊。简直难以置信。你可以看到他在行动中，他必须死。
I don't know.
You're not sure what to say?
I feel like it's stolen valor if I say...
Well, if I say...
oh Colorado and then Canada before that
people were like and I tell them what years I grew up there
they were like oh well you should just say Colorado
and I'm like yeah but developmentally
拉起我的工装裤。嘿，爸爸。嘿，爸爸。不，但我认为塑造我的大部分事情发生在我到了加利福尼亚之后，也就是七岁到现在。我是说，你知道，我记得盐湖城、波士顿、纽约的雪之类的东西，但在那之前的年龄。但真正塑造我的人格的事情在那之前并没有发生，对吧？
like those Canada years were important to me
well how much but really I mean for any of us
how much do you remember before nine years old
not a time yeah just a lot of screeching tires Johnny
not all of us had to black it out man
you know what I mean
oh yeah yeah Jake Bates
Jakey was trying to learn how to die on the set of a little
当然。我是说，所以我认为，好吧，我是说，没有，你知道，你的科罗拉多岁月那么多。你知道，9到17岁。我是说，那才是整个饼干。我是说，杰森，老实说。从，你知道，18岁到20多岁住在洛杉矶，那时你也看到了很多雪。是啊，是啊。让我们现实一点。
on the prairie and getting notes on a little less on the dying, Jake, okay?
Little Jakey bates with this bowl cut.
Have you ever seen photos?
Google Jason when he was a kid.
He's so fucking cute.
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
And you can see him on getting there in action and he's got to die.
让我们现实一点。那很现实。哈？耶稣。保时捷从华纳兄弟公司开出来，嘴里塞满了雪。你变得太邪恶了。耶稣。
Pulling up my overalls.
Hey, pa.
No, but I think most of what shaped me happened once I got to California,
which was seven till now.
I mean, you know, I remember snow and things like that in Salt Lake City, Boston, New York,
but in the ages before.
But nothing really shaped who I am happened before then, right?
哦，我们玩得很开心。哦，我们玩得很开心。所以伯文，你怎么去？所以医学预科化学？那是对的吗？那是？是啊，那是，我躲在它后面。真的吗？
Sure.
I mean, so I think, well, I mean, not as much as, you know, your Colorado years.
You know, 9 to 17.
I mean, that's the whole cookie right there.
I mean, Jason, let's be honest.
Living in L.A. from, you know, 18 and through your 20s, you saw a lot of snow then, too.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's be real.
好吧。因为我在看大学，我像，纯粹是被，就像，那里的喜剧场景是什么所激励。哦，好吧。所以，所以你……是在，
That's be real.
Huh?
Jesus.
Pornche peeling out of water, brothers
with a fucking beak full of snow.
You come so wicked.
Jesus.
以医学预科为幌子追求喜剧的意图，差不多。这就是你要说的吗？是啊。真的吗？我们刚才，呃，我们刚才，呃，在和科林谈论这个，对吧？
Oh, we had some fun.
Oh, we had fun.
So Bowen, how do you go?
So pre-med chemistry?
Is that right?
Is that?
Yeah, it was, I was taking cover behind it.
Really?
他在……类似。是啊，所以他，他要去哈佛学习，是吗，呃，经济学。经济学，然后他决定在坐着的时候稍微转向喜剧，所以你可以去西北大学或者就像你，你有技能，学术资格来真正为你自己获得一个你可以指望的职业，一个不错的健康基本工资和一些长寿等等，但你像，不，不，让我们选择喜剧，这就是我想投入全部的，哈？糟糕，糟糕，我是说，我是说谢天谢地它成功了，但现在谁在笑，但有趣，是啊。是啊，你做得很好。所以一切都成功了。
Okay.
Because I was looking at colleges
and I was like, purely motivated by, like,
what the comedy scenes were there.
Oh, okay.
So, so you...
It was between, like, Northwestern and NYU, yeah.
So you, but you, so you went with the,
但我有兴趣问科林那个，我也要问你同样的问题。它是，继续。嗯，我觉得哈佛，就像讽刺剧，就像，制度上就在那里。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得，现在我觉得，特别是在《周六夜现场》，就像，哦，纽约大学算是血统，而，就像，我不知道，10年前更多是哈佛流血。哦，好吧。有趣。
with the intention to pursue comedy
under the guise of pre-med,
pretty much. Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
Really?
We were just, uh,
we were just, uh, talking to Colin
just about this, right?
哦，真的吗？对吧？我不知道。所以那是思考的一部分，因为你最终去了纽约大学吗？是啊，是啊。是啊，所以那是，你认为那可能是《周六夜现场》的输送机。S&L是一个目标？
Where he was...
Similar.
Yeah, so he's, he's going into Harvard studying,
was it, uh, economics.
economics and then he decided to just sort of tack over to comedy when he's sitting at so you could go to northwestern or like you had you had the skills the academic qualifications to really get yourself a career that you could count on a nice healthy base salary and some longevity etc but you were like no no let's go with comedy that's what i want to put put it all in on huh terrible terrible i mean i mean thank god it works out but who's laughing now
But interesting, yeah.
Yeah, you're killing it.
So it all worked out.
S&L从来不是目标。S&L就像太，太遥不可及了。但最终发生的是，就像，来自我们纽约大学小圈子的人，我们那群，就像，怪胎和怪人，就像，被狂喜地带进了S&L宇宙飞船。然后我们像，哦，等等。所以现在我们有我们的小金丝雀之类的。我是说，这听起来很邪恶，但它……好吧，你是，它确实听起来。
But I was interested to ask Colin about that, and I'm going to ask you the same.
It was, go ahead.
Well, I feel like with Harvard, it's like the lampoon is, like, kind of institutionally there.
You know what I mean?
I feel like, now I feel like, especially at SNL, it's like, oh, NYU is sort of the pedigree,
whereas, like, I don't know, 10 years ago it was more Harvard bleeding.
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
听起来你在隐瞒什么。但我……你，你，你……你在做……你在做小品吗？你在做单口相声吗？是啊，你在UCB吗？是啊。
Oh, really?
Right?
I don't know.
So that was part of the thinking, because did you end up going to NYU?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So then that was, you thought of that as possibly a feeder for SNL.
S&L was a goal?
是啊。这是，我们是……我在德里克喜剧的这些男孩刚刚，就像，席卷现场之后进入纽约大学。那是唐纳德·格洛弗和……像D.C.皮尔森和多米尼克·迪克斯。像瑞秋·布鲁姆在大四。斯蒂芬·舒在那里做小品喜剧。
S&L was never the goal.
S&L was like too, too far out of reach.
But what ended up happening was, like, people from our little ilk at NYU,
our coterie of, like, freaks and weirdos were, like, being raptured up into the SNL spaceship.
And then we were like, oh, wait.
So now we have our little canaries or whatever.
I mean, it sounds nefarious, but it...
Well, were you, it does sound.
就像那是所有这些，就像，人们，就像，哦，他们有什么特别之处。然后，但在当时你不能说，就像，好吧，我们都会大获成功。你知道吗？它只是不是。你只是做了你所爱的。你永远不能大声说出来。是啊，是啊，是啊。
It sounds like you're hiding something.
But I...
Do you, do you, do you...
Were you doing...
Were you doing sketch?
Were you doing stand-up?
Yeah, were you at UCB?
Yeah.
是啊，当人们问你，就像，你有什么建议吗，这听起来太烦人了，我像，我，如果你能在正确的时间出现在正确的地点，但从来没有办法知道。是的，这是一个很好的观点。你在做任何事情同时来减轻你的风险吗？你知道，学习其他任何东西吗？
This was, we were...
I was going into NYU right after these boys from Derek comedy
had just sort of like stormed the scene.
It was Donald Glover and...
like D.C. Pearson and Dominic Dierkes.
Like Rachel Bloom was in her senior year.
Steph Schu was doing sketch comedy there.
学习化学，在贝尔维尤做志愿者，在贝尔维尤医院，贝尔维尤的急诊室，我在那里被解雇了，因为我不得不，就像，因为我在我的时间表上加了10分钟之类的。就像他们对心脏病发作一样认真。所以说关于。就像，他们不会让任何事情溜走。我们马上回来。
Like it was all these like people who were like,
oh, there's something special about them.
And then, but at the time you couldn't say,
like, well, we're all going to make it big.
You know? It just wasn't.
You just did what you loved.
You could never say that out loud.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
现在，回到节目。这真的很有趣。我读到在纽约大学当你学化学医学预科时，那是因为吴珊卓。你是《实习医生格蕾》中吴珊卓的超级粉丝。然后发生了什么，我觉得这很搞笑。来吧。
Yeah, and it sounds so annoying when people ask you,
like, would you have any advice?
And I'm like, I, if you can be at the right place at the right time,
but there's never any way of knowing.
Yes, that's a great point.
Were you doing anything simultaneously
to sort of mitigate your risk?
You know, studying anything else?
那不是一个段子。那不是一个段子。这不是一个段子。她的角色名字是克里斯蒂娜·杨。克里斯蒂娜·杨。克里斯汀。那不是很疯狂吗？这就像经典的，就像，你的电线交叉了，因为它就像，
Studying chemistry, volunteering at Bellevue,
at Bellevue Hospital, the ER at Bellevue,
where I got fired because I had to like,
because I added like 10 minutes to my time chart or something.
It was like they were serious as a heart attack.
so to speak about.
Like, they would not let anything slide.
We'll be right back.
并不是因为我看到了她才想成为医生。是因为一，我可能想演戏，二，因为我是一个崇拜女演员作品的男同性恋。就像，只是那两件事。是啊，这是一记组合拳。这是一记组合拳。是啊。
And now, back to the show.
This is really interesting.
I read that at NYU when you were chemistry pre-med,
that's because of Sandra O.
You were a huge fan of Sandra O.
on Graz Anatomy.
And then what happened, which I think is hilarious.
Come on.
是啊，所以。但化学，但化学不是，不是医学。你不会，你不会，不。你不是在学医学。所以，就像，一个人能……好吧，你在学什么，杰森？
That's not a bit.
It's not a bit.
And her character name is Christina Yang.
Christina Yang.
Christine. Isn't that crazy?
It's like the classic, like,
your wire's getting crossed for it was like,
让我们听听你对化学的想法。我想知道一个人能期待用化学学位获得什么样的职业。所以这很有趣。就像，在过去，工业这个词，对我来说，意味着……并不意味着任何好莱坞。它意味着，哦，就像，你在化学领域做工业工作，这意味着你为，就像，宝洁公司之类的公司工作。你，就像，制造除臭剂。
it wasn't that I wanted to be a doctor because I saw her.
It was because one,
I wanted to maybe act, and two,
because I was a gay man worshipping an actress's work.
Like, it was just those two things.
Yeah, it's a one-two punch.
That's a one-two punch.
Yeah.
对。对。陶氏，是啊。是啊。你制造这些，就像，你制造药品，或者你制造像……那对你来说是一个真正的兴趣。你打算追求那个。不，不，它不是。
Yeah, so.
But chemistry, but chemistry is not,
is not medicine.
You're not going to, you're not going to,
No.
You're not studying medicine.
So, like, what could one...
Well, what are you studying, Jason?
它一点也不真实。化学是因为它是完成学分阻力最小的路径。没有，就像，实际的兴趣。我是说，我知道一些东西。这是一个你掌握的学科。就像，你没有挣扎。就像，我在化学方面挣扎得很厉害。是啊。
Let's hear your thoughts on chemistry.
I want to know what kind of career one can anticipate with a chemistry degree.
So it's funny.
Like, back in the day, the word industry, to me, meant...
Didn't mean anything Hollywood.
It meant, oh, like, you're working an industry job in chemistry,
which means you work for, like, Procter & Gamble or something.
You, like, make deodorants.
这不简单。在公共汽车上？在公共汽车上？在什么？在公共汽车上？顺便说一句，没人对那个表示震惊。你说完之后我沉默了。我不是在寻找震惊。
Right.
Dow, yeah.
Yeah.
You make these, like, you make pharmaceuticals, or you make like...
That was a genuine interest for you.
You were going to pursue that.
No, no, it wasn't.
伯文，你从来没有联邦调查局，你从来没有因为那个化学专业且父亲涉及爆炸物的孩子而不得不敲联邦调查局的门。你没有得到快速访问？我应该有的。你没有旅行困难吗？我肯定我在名单上。
It was not genuine at all.
Chemistry was because it was the path of least resistance to getting, to, like, finishing my credits.
There was no, like, actual interest in it.
I mean, I know some stuff.
It was a subject you had a handle of.
Like, you didn't struggle.
Like, I struggled greatly with chemistry.
Yeah.
哦，不，你是对的。我从来没想过那个，威尔。我是说。但我只是想说所有疯狂的S&L的事情。所以你就像，我读到你就像我小时候一样
It's not simple.
On the bus?
On what?
By the way, nobody registered any shock on that.
I was silent after you said that.
I wasn't looking for shocked.
你会坐在你的房间里或者和你的家人一起在电视上做兔耳朵，在周六晚上看S&L。我过去常那样做，并独自在我兄弟的一个房间里看
Bowen, you never had the feds,
you never had to knock at the door of the feds
for the kid who's a chemistry major
whose dad was involved in a explosive.
You didn't get a quick visit?
I should have.
You didn't have trouble traveling?
I'm sure I'm on a list.
因为周围没人。然后，然后吴珊卓最终主持了节目，对吧？每个人都在哪儿？抱歉，每个人是谁？然后你姐姐把你介绍给S&L，然后你在高中被投票选为毕业班最有可能上S&L的人？
Oh, no, you're right.
I never thought of that, Will.
I mean.
But I wanted to just say all the crazy
SNL stuff.
So you were like,
I read you were like me
when you were a kid
因为那就像是我们最高级形容词的华丽、修饰过的语言。它就像，而不是像班级小丑，它就像最有可能上S&L。对，对，对，对。但有很多，我是毕业班最有可能在毕业典礼上绊倒的人。但没有。你绊倒了吗？
you would sit in your room
or with your family
and do the bunny ears
on the TV
and get S&L on Saturday night.
I used to do that
and watch it by myself
in one of my brother's rooms
是啊，我确实绊倒了，实际上。在什么上？迷幻药还是蘑菇？嘿，哦，嘿，来吧伙计们，让我们都活着。让我们看起来活着。让我们看起来活着。不，但我只是觉得那太疯狂了。所以你看了它，你姐姐说，
because nobody was around.
And then, and then Sandra
ends up posting the show, right?
Where was everybody?
Sorry, who was everybody?
And then your sister introduced you
to SNL, and then you were voted senior most likely to be on SNL
in your high school?
然后你被投票选上了，然后你去了那儿，然后玛格丽特·曹在那儿。有这么多箭头指向你将要上那个节目。这太疯狂了。我猜，我猜。然后，但然后，所以当试镜发生时，所有那些东西都涌进来了
Because that was like the florid,
sort of like embellished language for our superlatives.
It was like, instead of like class clown,
it was like most likely to be on SNL.
Right, right, right, right.
But there's so many, I was senior most likely to trip at graduation.
But there's no.
Did you?
你感觉到了赌注和压力吗？还是你有点冷漠？但让我们弄清楚，就像，那个试镜是怎么发生的，然后那种感觉？就像，什么是，是啊，你是怎么进入机器的？所以说到“笑话而已”，那过去是管道。就像S&L的人才会在夏天去“笑话而已”
Yeah, I did, actually.
On what?
Acid or shrooms?
Hey, oh, hey, come on guys, let's all be alive.
Let's look alive.
No, but I just think that's so wild.
And so you watch it, your sister said,
他们会挑选他们的人。我从来没到过那个阶段。所以我像，我猜这对我来说不在牌里。但然后，就像，我当时的经理说，整理一个磁带，五分钟，就像标准的，什么的，切入点。我像，他们永远，永远不会他妈的雇佣一个像那样的阴柔的亚洲人。就像，他们为什么会需要那个？
then you got voted for it,
then you went there, and then Margaret Cho was there.
There's so many arrows pointing
that you were going to be on the show.
It's just crazy.
I guess, I guess.
And then, but then, so when the audition happens,
does all that stuff flood in
所以出于一时兴起，我像，没人会看到这个磁带。所以让我只是，就像，胡闹，做对我来说有趣的事情。然后不知何故溜过去了。但这很自由。这对每个人来说都是一个很好的教训。那一定，你一定，那种感觉，就像，去他妈的。就像，有点像杰森所说的，就像，那种你正在做它，并且能够，就像，在没有网的情况下做它，因为你只是不。
and you feel the stakes and the pressure of it?
Or were you kind of indifferent?
But let's figure out, like,
how did that audition happen and then that feeling?
Like, what was the, yeah,
How did you get into the machine?
So speaking of Just for Laughs, that used to be the pipeline.
Like the SNL talent people would go to Just For Laughs in the summer
不是你不关心。是性感的冷漠吗？这是杰森喜欢说的性感的冷漠。对。一定感觉很好，能够只是有点做什么是。好吧。我想我是在和对的人说话，但我只是在某处读到这个。我真的没有任何关于它的知识。
and they would pick out their people.
I never made it to that stage.
And so I was like, I guess it's not in the cards for me.
But then, like, my manager at the time said,
put together a tape, five minutes, like the standard, whatever, entry point.
And I was like, they'll never, ever fucking hire an effeminate Asian guy
like on that show.
Like, why would they ever need that?
但这就是那件事，就像，它不像易普症，但它就像高尔夫球手在他们太专注于挥杆时有这个。他们只是，就像，失去了所有的能力。他们失去了所有的能力。这是当你，就像，不在心流状态，而是当你没有考虑，就像，微观决定。这是当你，就像，谁在乎？对。
So on a lark, I was like, no one's ever going to see this tape.
So let me just, like, fuck around and do what's funny for me.
And then somehow slipped through.
That's freeing, though.
That's a good lesson for everyone.
That must have been, you must have, that feeling of, like, fuck it.
Like, kind of going to what Jason was saying, like, that feeling of you're doing it
and being able to, like, do it without a net because you just don't.
花样滑冰运动员有这个。就像运动员总体上有这个。对。就像假装没人看着。本田P。本田P。而且我认为……本田P。
It's not you don't care.
Is it sexy indifference?
It's a sexy indifference that Jason likes to say.
Right.
must have felt really good being able to just kind of do what is.
Okay.
I think I'm talking to the right people, but I just read this somewhere.
I don't really have any knowledge of it.
该死，伙计们，我有多年轻？但这确实是真的。我确实一直都在想那个。你想到……好吧，在高尔夫球中，他们谈论，就像，抓得太紧。但生活中确实有那种抓得太紧的概念，在任何那种事情上。
But it's that thing that like, it's like not the yips, but it's like golfers have this
when they're a little too focused on the swing.
They just like lose all prowess.
They lose all capability.
It's when you're like, not in a flow state, but it's when you're not thinking of like
the micro decisions.
It's when you're like, who cares?
Right.
当你那样做时，那就是我的意思。你一定感觉真的，天哪，我敢打赌那是一个巨大的优势，因为其他人都在做他们的磁带，他们太紧张了，因为他们必须把它做好。是啊，是啊。而且我真的不在乎，是啊。
Figure skaters have this.
It's like athletes have this overall.
Right.
It's like pretend like no one's watching.
Hondo P.
Honda P.
And I think...
Hondo P.
所以我读到这个，希望这是悲剧性的搞笑而不是仅仅是悲剧。如果你想谈论它，我们不必。但我被一个事实迷住了，你的父母在你17岁时把你送到了科罗拉多的转换疗法。这很搞笑。这就是为什么。它实际上是。
Fuck, guys, how young am I?
But it is true.
I do think about that all the time.
You think about...
Well, literally in golf, they talk about, like,
gripping too tight.
But there is that notion of gripping too tight
in life on any of that stuff.
是啊，我像，有一些喜剧，可能有很多喜剧来自那有多可怕，是啊？绝对，因为有八周。所以喜剧开始了，整个那种场合，也就是最后通牒。所以，就像，我不出柜。我，就像，被发现是同性恋，基于家庭电脑。还记得那些吗？
And when you do that, that's what I meant.
You must have felt really like,
God, I bet you that was such an advantage
because everybody else is doing their tapes
and they're so tight
because they've got to get it right.
Yep, yep.
And I didn't really care, yeah.
它就像，我父母在家庭电脑上，就像，伯文，这是什么？哦，他们看到了。一张闷热的、肮脏的、肮脏的照片。浏览你的搜索，你的搜索历史。那是一个聊天窗口。哦哦。那是一个聊天窗口。你得关掉那些，伯文。
So this I read, and hopefully this is tragically hilarious
and not just tragic.
If you want to talk about it, we don't have to.
But I'm fascinated by the fact that your parents
sent you to conversion therapy in Colorado when you were 17.
It was hilarious.
That's why.
It actually was.
你得关掉那些。这是一个我们都在共享的家庭电脑。是啊。那是它吗？哇。完全正确。而你只是走开去拿可乐，然后……去拿可卡因。
Yeah, I'm like there's some comedy, probably a lot of comedy
from how horrible that was, yeah?
Definitely, because there was eight weeks.
So the comedy begins and the whole sort of occasioning of it,
which was the ultimatum.
So, like, I don't come out.
I, like, am discovered to be gay based on the family computer.
Remember those?
是啊。所以你没关你的窗口。我没关我的窗口。所以妈妈把它打印出来了。打印出文字记录。哦，天哪。你多大？哦，天哪。
It was, like, my parents going on the family computer being, like, Bowen, what's this?
Oh, and they saw.
A sultry, dirty, dirty picture.
Going through your search, your search history.
It was a chat window.
Uh-oh.
You got to close those, Bowen.
17岁。好吧。哦，不。所以她在你面前摇晃纸，说，这是什么？她说这是什么。而且你得在上面多加一点魁北克味，你知道吗？
You got to close those.
There's a family computer we're all sharing.
Yep.
Is that what it was?
Wow.
Exactly.
And you just walked away to get a Coke and...
To get cocaine.
她说，她，她，然后它就是，它就是疯狂的。而且它就像，我每天回家，我父母在餐桌上哭泣。
Yeah.
So you didn't close your window.
I didn't close my window.
So mom prints it out.
Prince out the transcript.
Oh, God.
How old are you?
我像，我必须纠正这一点。就像，我怎么能造成这么大的痛苦？所以，最后通牒是，它变得有趣了，我保证。最后通牒是，
17.
Okay.
Oh, no.
So she shakes the paper in front of you and says,
Kiskase?
She said Kestkese.
And you got to put a little bit more quibiqua on it,
do you know?
17. 好的。噢，不。所以她把纸在你面前晃了晃，说，Kiskase？她说的是Kestkese。你得再多加点quibiqua，你知道吗？
She said,
she lo,
she, and then it was,
it was crazy.
And it was like,
I would be coming,
I would be coming home to my parents
sobbing at the dinner table every day.
她说，她看，她，然后那真是，真是太疯狂了。就像我每天回到父母家时，都会在餐桌上哭泣一样。
And I was like,
I have to make this right.
Like, how could I cause this much pain?
And so,
the ultimatum was,
it gets funny,
I promise.
The ultimatum was,
我当时想，我必须纠正这一切。天哪，我怎么会造成这么大的痛苦？所以，最后通牒是，这会变得很有趣，我保证。最后通牒是，
uh,
either you stay in state in Colorado,
go to Boulder,
live with us,
or you can go to college with your sister
if you go to conversion therapy.
But the punchline is my sister was at
the gayest school in the country, NYU.
嗯，要么你留在科罗拉多州，去博尔德，和我们住在一起，要么如果你去接受转化治疗，你就可以和你姐姐一起上大学。但重点是，我姐姐当时在全国最“基”的学校，纽约大学。
Wow.
So I was like, sure, I'll do the conversion therapy.
It was eight weeks in the summer,
and it actually became great bonding time
because it was in Colorado Springs,
two-hour drive up and down from Denver.
My dad and I would, like, bond in the car
and just, like, actually get to know each other
哇。所以我当时就想，好吧，我去做转化治疗。那是在夏天，为期八周，实际上这成了一段很棒的亲子时光，因为它在科罗拉多斯普林斯，离丹佛往返两个小时车程。我和我爸会在车里聊天，就像，真正地去了解彼此
for the first time as, like, adults or something.
And then the guy is such a quack
that by like the eighth session, whatever,
like we're going through like
some diluted version of like
cognitive behavioral therapy
where he's like trying to like put me in my body
like anytime I've been attracted to a guy
第一次以成年人的身份，或者类似这样的方式。然后那个家伙简直是个庸医，大概到第八次咨询的时候，不管怎样，我们正在经历某种稀释版的认知行为疗法，他试图让我进入我的身体，每当我被一个男人吸引时
like it was because you were miserable
it's because you were like in pain
and I'm like...
But no, no, no. Then the last session...
This makes me sick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It is what it is.
So the second to last session
就说那是因为你很痛苦，是因为你处于某种折磨中，我就想……但根本不是那样。然后最后一次咨询……这让我感到恶心。是啊，是啊，是啊。事实就是这样。所以倒数第二次咨询
my dad is asking him for referrals in New York.
He was like, Bowens of going to New York.
Do you have any one there who does this kind of work?
He's like, sure, I'll come up with some names next time.
The next week at the last session, Stonewall.
Yeah, go to Stonewall and go to pieces in the West Village.
The last session, he, like, walks me, he, like, starts to go into this anecdote
in the third person about one of his former patients.
我爸在向他要纽约的推荐人。他说，鲍恩要去纽约了。你那里有做这种工作的人吗？他说，没问题，下次我给你几个名字。下周最后一次咨询时，石墙酒吧。对，去石墙酒吧，去西村的Pieces酒吧。最后一次咨询，他开始用第三人称讲他以前一个病人的轶事。
And he's like, yeah, my former patient just gets off at the side of the road in San Bernardino,
which is not where you want to be late at night.
and his car broke down,
and then he goes to a Denny's,
and then the waiter's making eyes at him,
and then my therapist starts to shift into the first person.
And then I was like,
am I really gonna have sex with this guy?
他说，是的，我以前的病人就在圣贝纳迪诺的路边下车了，那可不是你大晚上想去的地方。他的车坏了，然后他去了丹尼餐厅，服务员对他暗送秋波，然后我的治疗师开始切换到第一人称。当时我就想，我真的要和这个家伙发生关系吗？
And then I did.
And then he caught himself shifting into the first person.
Oh, my God.
And then, like, the blood left his face.
And then in that moment, it was like,
oh, I've just undone all of this work that we've,
this, like, fake, phony work
然后我真的做了。接着他意识到自己切换到了第一人称。天哪。天哪。然后，他脸色煞白。那一刻，我就觉得，哦，我刚刚把我过去八周所做的所有这些工作，这些虚假的、伪造的工作
that we've been doing for the past eight weeks.
Wow.
And then I was like, wow.
none of this was real.
I walk out.
I've wasted my time.
He pulls out a little piece of paper.
He's like, so I couldn't find anyone in New York who does this,
全都毁了。哇。然后我就想，哇。这一切都不是真的。我走出来。我浪费了我的时间。他拿出一张小纸条。他说，我没能在纽约找到做这个的人，
but there is a guy in Trenton, New Jersey.
And then my dad and I were like, well, I used to date him.
I used to date him.
My dad and I'm like, oh, I guess, yeah, I'll take the train out to Jersey to
see this person.
Just trying to like, just trying to like swat this away.
I was like, there's no way I'm ever going to continue this.
And so I was like in the closet for like a year at NYU.
但在新泽西州的特伦顿有一个人。然后我和我爸就说，嗯，我以前和他约会过。我以前和他约会过。我爸和我，我就想，哦，我想，好吧，我会坐火车去新泽西见这个人。只是想，只是想把这事打发掉。我当时想，我绝不可能继续下去了。所以我在纽约大学出柜前大概在柜子里待了一年。
But then like all these comedy nerds that I was friends with were like, you're gay.
And then by sophomore year I was out.
But, but Bowen, look, we're not talking about the 50s here.
We're talking about just a half a dozen years ago.
And it sounds like you, and you're in Colorado, which is progressive-ish.
And you're great friends with your parents, it sounds like.
I mean, notwithstanding the fact.
that they want you to go through conversion therapy,
但后来我那些喜剧书呆子朋友们都说，你是同性恋。到了大二我就出柜了。但是，鲍恩，听着，我们谈论的不是50年代。我们谈论的是仅仅六年前的事。听起来你当时在科罗拉多，那里还算进步。而且听起来你和父母关系很好。我是说，撇开他们想让你接受转化治疗这一点不谈，
you're still getting along with them
and you're driving and you're bonding with your dad
and blah, blah, blah.
Like, how, I don't understand how all this can sort of match
because at what point, didn't you at some point say,
yeah, no, no, guys, I am gay, I'm happy.
And you love me and you're happy with me
and like, why are we trying to convert anything?
你仍然和他们相处得很好，你们一起开车，你和你爸爸建立了感情，等等等等。我不明白这一切怎么能协调起来，因为在某个时刻，你难道没有在某个时候说，是的，不，不，伙计们，我是同性恋，我很开心。你们爱我，你们对我感到满意，为什么我们要试图转化什么呢？
Right, right.
They, it's not really a religious thing for them,
or it wasn't, like,
I think for them it was just this cultural thing coming out of China.
Yeah, yeah.
Right.
Yeah, well, it's not even on a political alignment.
It's just them thinking like, oh, I don't want my child to have a worse, harder life.
对，对。对他们来说，这并不是真正的宗教问题，或者曾经不是，我想对他们来说，这只是来自中国的一种文化产物。是啊，是啊。对。是的，这甚至不是政治立场问题。这只是他们觉得，哦，我不希望我的孩子过上更糟糕、更艰难的生活。
And for them, like they, so my dad kept saying to me was, speaking of like the Straw Mudhut sort of ethos, he was like, where I grew up, this doesn't happen.
Like, there are people like this.
And I was like, no, there are, they just had no concept of it.
And so they are both scientists, engineers,
they think in terms of solutions.
They think in terms of what can be done to change this.
Right.
I understand.
对他们来说，我爸一直对我说，说到那种“草泥屋”式的精神，他说，我长大的地方，这种情况不会发生。就像，没有这样的人。我说，不，有的，他们只是完全没有这个概念。他们都是科学家、工程师，他们从解决方案的角度思考。他们从可以做些什么来改变这一点来思考。对。我明白了。
I read when you said,
I read you said your dad will still occasionally suggest
you could try women and you call it almost endearing homophobia.
It's so sweet.
Isn't it so sweet?
That's so funny.
That is so funny.
It's so nice.
我读到你说，我读到你说你爸爸偶尔还是会建议你试试女人，你称之为“近乎可爱的恐同”。太甜了。难道不甜吗？太搞笑了。太搞笑了。太好了。
Bless him.
Are they, have you guys had the conversation?
of like, I guess it turns out there was nothing to really worry about.
Right?
We've had, oh, yeah.
Yeah, great.
I think we've done the, we've patched it up really nicely.
Like, they have apologized.
祝福他。你们谈过吗？关于，我想结果证明根本没什么可担心的。对吧？我们谈过，哦，是的。是的，太好了。我想我们已经把这件事处理得非常好了。他们道歉了。
I've always kind of understood where they've come from.
Yeah, it sounds like, yeah.
Sounds like you had a lot of understanding of it.
Like, even early on, like, understanding that like, A, you wanted to go to college,
so you were doing it to kind of just go through the motion so you could go.
But it does sound like you, I don't know.
There's no hint of any sort of anger towards it.
Like you were like, yeah, I get it.
我一直都能理解他们的出发点。是的，听起来是这样。听起来你对它有很多理解。就像，即使在早期，理解到，A，你想上大学，所以你只是走个过场，这样你就能去了。但听起来你，我不知道。没有任何愤怒的迹象。就像你说，是的，我懂。
I know where they're coming from.
That's very kind.
It shows a kind of spirit, to be honest.
Yeah, yeah, I love that.
So I want to go back to, if you don't mind.
There's never a subject that Sean doesn't want to get away from every subject.
He's got his question.
He's never happy where he is.
我知道他们的出发点。这非常善良。老实说，这展现了一种精神。是的，是的，我喜欢这样。所以我想回到，如果你不介意的话。从来没有肖恩不想逃避的话题，每个话题他都想逃避。他有他的问题。他对自己所在的地方从不满意。
He's always trying to leave where he is.
100%.
We're enjoying Bowen.
We're talking to him.
We're having a real conversation.
Look, if you want, we can talk about being gay all on day long.
No, I don't want to, whatever.
Should I just go?
他总是试图离开他所在的地方。百分之百。我们很享受鲍恩。我们在和他交谈。我们在进行真正的对话。听着，如果你想，我们可以整天谈论同性恋。不，我不想，随便吧。我应该直接走吗？
Okay, so
So the SNL screen says we kind of covered that
But I want to talk about
So your first you were hired as a writer
At such a young age, which is amazing
You weren't even on camera.
Sure. Sure.
And how old were you?
好吧，所以SNL的屏幕上说我们已经涵盖了这一点，但我想要谈谈，所以你第一次被聘为编剧是在这么年轻的时候，这太棒了。你甚至没有出镜。当然，当然。你当时多大？
27?
That's a reasonable age?
That's pretty young, though.
But the first time you were on camera,
which made me laugh.
I laughed so hard at you playing Kim Jong-un.
Oh, thanks.
It was so fucking...
27岁？那是个合理的年龄？不过还是挺年轻的。但你第一次出镜的时候，让我笑了。你扮演金正恩让我笑得好大声。哦，谢谢。这太他妈的……
It was so funny.
Jason, are you laughing?
Just thinking about it.
Oh my God, I gotta find that.
It was so funny.
I mean, I love it.
Thanks.
And then the first thing that ever went super viral
太搞笑了。杰森，你在笑吗？只是想到它。天哪，我得找出来看看。太搞笑了。我是说，我喜欢它。谢谢。然后第一件真正病毒式传播的事情
was you played the iceberg,
the, what was it?
The Iceberg, you'd think the Titanic.
Yeah, the Iceberg is going to be a Titanic.
Yeah, Sean, the Iceberg is a killer.
Which is so funny.
What was it like?
Talk to me about being a writer and then going,
是你扮演了冰山，那个，是什么来着？冰山，你以为是泰坦尼克号。是的，冰山要成为泰坦尼克号。是的，肖恩，冰山是个杀手。这太搞笑了。感觉如何？跟我说说作为编剧，然后变成，
hey, you know what?
We think you should be a writer.
featured player and you're Kim Jong-un and you're this iceberg that hit the Titanic hit.
The same sketch?
No, no, no.
What was the same sketch?
It was him.
It was him all along.
嘿，你知道吗？我们认为你应该成为一名特约演员，你是金正恩，你是撞上泰坦尼克号的冰山。同一个小品？不，不，不。同一个小品是什么？一直都是他。
Was the feeling like, oh, my, like, how nervous were you to be doing the thing that you set
out to do on the first time?
So nervous.
So what I remember from the Kim Jong-un thing was, it was when Sandra O hosted, as you said.
Yeah, that's right.
I was a writer.
and...
Insane.
感觉是不是像，哦，天哪，第一次做你着手要做的事情时，你有多紧张？太紧张了。关于金正恩那个小品，我记得的是，正如你所说，那是吴珊卓主持的时候。是的，没错。我当时是编剧，而且……疯狂。
Insane, insane.
And so they...
Just insane.
Just insane in synchronicity, et cetera.
Yeah.
I know.
It's all very kismity.
How was that conversation when you went...
疯狂，疯狂。所以他们……简直疯狂。简直是同步的疯狂，等等。我知道。这一切都非常巧合。当你去……的时候，那次谈话怎么样？
Did you go up to her at some point and say,
hey, so I just got to tell you really quick.
Yeah.
When I was a quote...
Did you tell her how much...
Your both...
You're responsible.
Yeah.
你有没有在某个时候走到她面前说，嘿，我得快速告诉你。是的。当我还是个引用……你有没有告诉她多少……你们两个……你们有责任。是的。
Yes.
Okay, good.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So I...
I would like do these...
Pre-Tik-Tuk, I would do these things where I would just like...
Just kind of match, like, on a lip-flap, perfect level.
Like...
是的，好的。哦，是的，是的。所以我……我会做这些……在TikTok之前，我会做这些事情，我会只是……只是匹配，在对口型方面达到完美水平。就像……
the little like,
oh my God.
Whatever, recitals and monologues.
And I did her.
I saw you lip sync the whole
monologue from Devil Wars Prada.
I did that.
I did, yeah.
那些，哦，天哪。不管是什么，朗诵和独白。我模仿了她。我看到你对口型表演了《穿普拉达的女王》里的整段独白。我做了。我做了，是的。
So like, you've got to see it.
It's unbelievable.
I've scrubbed them.
I don't know why I'm like so ashamed to see them now.
Because they're so like pre-
But it's incredible.
I don't know.
They seem prehistoric to me.
所以，你一定要看看。简直不可思议。我把它们删了。我不知道为什么我现在觉得很羞愧看到它们。因为它们太像前……但它们太不可思议了。我不知道。它们对我来说看起来像史前时代的。
But anyway, but Sandra and I met
before she hosted.
And then she hosted these other writers,
Streeter Seidel writes me into the sketch
where I play Kim Jong-un.
I don't have context at the time.
and they don't put my prescription in the glasses that I wear.
And so I had to be off book, basically,
但无论如何，我和珊卓在她主持之前就见过面。然后她主持了，其他编剧，斯特里特·塞德尔把我写进了那个我扮演金正恩的小品里。我当时没有背景，而且他们没有把我戴的眼镜换成我的处方镜片。所以我基本上必须背下台词，
which is not what you do at SNL, as you guys know.
Like, I used to be off book.
I had to, like, call a Korean friend, Karen Chi,
who used to write at Seth Myers.
I was like, can you translate these lines into Korean for me,
learned the Korean, was off book on a foreign language.
Whoa.
Then it was just a million different things.
这在SNL是不可能的，你们知道的。就像，我以前必须背下台词。我不得不给一个韩国朋友打电话，凯伦·奇，她以前在塞斯·梅耶斯那里写过稿子。我说，你能帮我把这些台词翻译成韩语吗？我学会了韩语，背下了外语台词。哇。然后就是一百万件不同的事情。
And I had a sketch on that week that I had to be.
I sat under the bleachers next to Lauren Michaels in the Kim Jong-un costume.
getting notes.
Like, I'm in this Kim Jong-un costume
and he turns to me,
he's like, maybe we cut the Canaan sooner
or whatever.
I'm like, this is the most surreal,
那一周我还有一个小品。我穿着金正恩的服装坐在劳恩·迈克尔斯旁边的看台上。听取意见。就像，我穿着这身金正恩的服装，他转向我，说，也许我们早点切掉迦南或者什么的。我说，这是我经历过最超现实的，
that's still the most surreal week of my life that I have.
Pass the whispering angel.
Did you...
It's my favorite, it's on ice.
Did you, God, it must have been...
Was it weird being, all the years you were there
just knowing that you were the smartest person
in the building, you're learning languages,
那仍然是我一生中最超现实的一周。递给我那杯Whispering Angel。你……这是我的最爱，它在冰里。你，天哪，那一定……在你待在那里的所有岁月里，知道自己是楼里最聪明的人，你在学习语言，
you're memorizing...
No way.
I mean, come on.
No, no.
I was no Colin.
I was no economics major.
He doesn't know, does he know French and Korean?
Yeah, you can't learn Korean and then memorize it.
你在背诵……不可能。我是说，得了吧。不，不。我不是科林。我不是经济学专业的。他不知道，他懂法语和韩语吗？是的，你不能学会韩语然后背下来。
Okay, so wait, now tell me about this.
When you were 15 years old, you were doing improv at bars?
Oh, yeah.
Is that true?
Yeah, but this is so, that doesn't age well.
I feel like.
I think that's fascinating.
You got to start on things.
好吧，等等，现在告诉我这个。你15岁的时候在酒吧做即兴表演？哦，是的。那是真的吗？是的，但这太，我觉得这不太经得起时间考验。我觉得这很迷人。你得从某些事情开始。
How did you get in?
Like, for young people listening,
It's like, oh, if he can get doing improv, but how did you get into the bars?
What happened?
So there's a theater in Denver called the Bovine Metropolis Theater.
It took me years to figure out it's a play on Cowtown.
Anyway, Bovine Metropolis.
But anyway, they would do like Monday nights, like kind of open mic situations.
你是怎么进去的？就像，对于听节目的年轻人来说，就像，哦，如果他能做即兴表演，但你是怎么进酒吧的？发生了什么？丹佛有一家剧院叫Bovine Metropolis Theater。我花了好几年才发现这是“Cowtown”（牛城）的双关语。总之，Bovine Metropolis。但无论如何，他们会在周一晚上做类似开放麦的情况。
And our sponsor at the school, who is also my calculus teacher, this wonderful educator named Adrian Holguyen.
Calculus chemistry.
I know, I know.
Oh, stop it.
You guys, that's enough.
So we, we, they would, it was awful.
I don't know who, who let their kids go drive into the city on Mondays.
I thought that was so interesting.
我们学校的赞助人，也是我的微积分老师，一位名叫阿德里安·霍尔吉恩的优秀教育家。微积分、化学。我知道，我知道。哦，别说了。你们这些家伙，够了。所以我们，他们会，那太糟糕了。我不知道是谁让他们的孩子周一开车进城的。我觉得那太有趣了。
Yeah.
But, but it was great.
It was embarrassing.
Like, like, we, we bombed constantly in front of people who did not give a shit if we lived.
Like, it was like, it didn't matter if we did well.
It was just about, like, it's that Chris Rock thing.
I'm just, like, bomb a million times.
Right, right, right.
是的。但，但那很棒。很尴尬。就像，我们，我们不断地在那些根本不在乎我们死活的人面前搞砸。就像，我们表现好不好根本不重要。这只是关于，就像克里斯·洛克说的那样。我只是，搞砸一百万次。对，对，对。
Right.
Where did your sense of.
humor come from? I mean, your parents, you say
they're both scientists,
but maybe are they super funny?
I mean, no.
How did you develop it? Was it
just watching?
对。你的幽默感是从哪里来的？我是说，你父母，你说他们都是科学家，但也许他们超级幽默？我是说，没有。你是怎么培养出来的？只是看吗？
It was, guys, this is,
and I hope you guys can accept this
or receive this. It's like, I think it was
like, do you remember, like, this is the value
in like network comedies, right?
It's like, it was everybody
like having the same frame of reference
as to what was funny.
伙计们，这是，我希望你们能接受或领会这一点。就像，我想这就像，你们记得吗，这就是电视喜剧的价值，对吧？就像，每个人对什么是好笑的都有相同的参照框架。
It was like, it was watching you guys
Sorry to put you on a pedestal, but it was, it was that.
Take your time through here.
No, go ahead.
Don't finish.
It was, it was like, going to school.
It was going to school the next day being like, oh my God.
Did you guys watch a rest of development?
就像，看着你们这些家伙，抱歉把你们捧上神坛，但确实是，就是那样。慢慢来。不，继续。别停。就像，第二天去学校，就像，哦，天哪。你们看《发展受阻》了吗？
Or it was like, and Sean, like, after I did this thing.
So, Jason, my farewell sketch was with Cher.
And I thought, and I was constantly thinking back to Sean, Sean and Cher together.
Right.
And it was just, I mean, that's just like peak guest star.
God, Sean, I love to be doing this of a sheriff of a share.
Oh, thanks.
So, guys.
或者就像，肖恩，在我做完这件事之后。所以，杰森，我的告别小品是和雪儿一起的。我想，我一直在回想肖恩，肖恩和雪儿在一起。对。那简直就是客串明星的巅峰。天哪，肖恩，我喜欢和雪儿一起做这个。哦，谢谢。所以，伙计们。
Was that a moment for you when, when Will and Grace really hit their stride?
And, I mean, yes, there was a moment when Ellen came out.
That was the big sort of watershed moment.
But then Will and Grace, I believe, followed that, Shawnee.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And was that, did you feel a sense of like, well, there may be a spot for me?
I might be able to just light my hair on fire and say, yeah, I'm not closet about anything.
there is room for me and us and etc.
当《威尔和格蕾丝》真正进入状态时，对你来说是一个时刻吗？而且，我是说，是的，艾伦出柜的时候有一个时刻。那是重大的分水岭时刻。但随后《威尔和格蕾丝》紧随其后，肖尼。是的，是的，是的。那是，你有没有感觉到一种，嗯，也许有一个位置适合我？我可能可以点燃我的头发说，是的，我对此毫不隐瞒。有我的空间，有我们的空间，等等。
Yes?
I don't know if I got that far
because I'm telling you guys,
like I never, I would have been,
if you would ask me right as I moved to New York,
or like right out of college,
if you'd ask me what my like ideal job was in showbiz,
it would have been just to be in a room,
是吗？我不知道我是否想得那么远，因为我告诉你们，我从来没有，如果你们在我刚搬到纽约时，或者刚大学毕业时问我，我在演艺圈的理想工作是什么，那只会是待在一个房间里，
just to be in a writer's room.
Right.
I never placed myself in those things.
And I don't know if it's about like, you know, representation stuff.
It was more just about like,
I'm good just knowing the inner work.
I would like watch The Simpsons.
and like study the credits.
待在一个编剧室里。对。我从来没有把自己放在那些位置上。我不知道这是否关于，你知道，代表性之类的东西。这更多是关于，我只要了解内部工作就很好。我会看《辛普森一家》，然后研究演职员表。
Like I was, it was about that.
It was like, that was the granular kind of comedy thing
that I was working with.
But watching Sean, I think it was about, like,
oh, this is the language, this is the vocabulary of like,
or this is just a sensibility of what, like, gay, queer humor is.
And then it turns out it's universal.
And if I could do that and take what Sean's doing
就像我，就是关于那个。就像，那是颗粒度很细的喜剧，我在处理它。但看着肖恩，我想这是关于，哦，这就是语言，这就是词汇，或者这就是同性恋、酷儿幽默的感性。结果发现它是普遍的。如果我能做到这一点，并采用肖恩正在做的事情，
and just dial it in half,
then you could have something good.
You get some kind of future.
Like, if you could just make it somewhat palatable.
You know what I mean?
And then you could.
I can only...
I can say that to the guy who's got four SAG Awards and Emmys and Tony's.
然后稍微调整一下，那你就能做出好东西。你会得到某种未来。就像，如果你能让它稍微可口一点。你们懂我的意思吗？然后你就能。我只能……我对那个拥有四个演员工会奖、艾美奖和托尼奖的家伙说这些。
Who counts four?
Sean, me, are you like a...
Are you an Academy Award way from an EGOT?
No.
But I...
And I'm an E.
You're Tony and your Emmy.
谁在数四个？肖恩，我，你离EGOT（艾美奖、格莱美奖、奥斯卡奖、托尼奖）还差一个奥斯卡奖吗？不。但我……不。我是E。你是托尼奖和艾美奖。
And you're an E.
And Olivier, so I have a toe.
Oh.
And a sag.
And a toe's.
I have toes.
I have saggy toes.
你是E。还有奥利弗奖，所以我有一个脚趾。哦。还有一个演员工会奖。还有一个演员工会奖。还有脚趾。我有脚趾。我有下垂的脚趾。
I've saggy toes.
Saggy toes.
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
Wait, Bowen, so, but Jason, if you haven't seen it,
his last, Bowen's last sketch, his goodbye sketch,
took place in a Delta lounge,
我有下垂的脚趾。下垂的脚趾。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目。等等，鲍恩，所以，但是杰森，如果你还没看过，他最后，鲍恩的最后一个小品，他的告别小品，发生在达美航空休息室，
and it was with Ariana Grande and Cher.
And it was so clever how you wrote it,
or how you and the writers wrote it, whatever,
that your wife calls you, and, well, can I say?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
You said, I forget what it was about,
But it was eggnog, right?
Yes.
那是和爱莉安娜·格兰德以及雪儿一起的。你写的方式，或者你和编剧们写的方式，不管怎样，太聪明了，你妻子给你打电话，而且，嗯，我可以说吗？是的，是的，是的，当然。你说，我忘了是关于什么的，但那是蛋酒，对吧？是的。
And Ariana Grande's character...
It was the Christmas show.
Yes.
And she says, all the eggnog you've made over the years,
some of it was great, some of it was rotten.
And you say, and a lot of it got cut.
And a lot of it got cut.
Which is really cute.
爱莉安娜·格兰德的角色……那是圣诞节目。是的。她说，这些年来你做的所有蛋酒，有些很棒，有些烂透了。你说，还有很多被剪掉了。还有很多被剪掉了。这真的很可爱。
And it was very emotional.
It was really clever.
It was really clever to do a Delta lounge.
And you were saying...
It was really...
It's a little...
Yeah, it's a kind of...
It's obviously like allegorical, metaphorical, whatever.
而且非常感人。这真的很聪明。做一个达美航空休息室真的很聪明。你说……这真的很……这有点……是的，这显然是寓言式的、隐喻式的，不管怎样。
But I was like, oh, something about departures.
Yeah, an airport.
It was great.
It was the Christmas show.
It was like, oh, something about like...
Jason got it finally.
Jason got it.
I got it.
但我当时想，哦，关于离别的事情。是的，机场。这很棒。那是圣诞节目。就像，哦，关于……杰森终于明白了。杰森明白了。我明白了。
Just takes me a bit.
He's this old man who works through the Egnog station, and then he's like, oh, like,
eggnog, it's not for everyone, but the people who like it really like it, and they're my kind of people.
And like, that's like the whole message of it all.
And then Cher comes out as the boss.
Yeah, it was really funny.
That is sweet.
What was, talk, walk us through the thinking about leaving and the, and the, and the
只是花了我一点时间。他是那个在蛋酒站工作的老人，然后他说，哦，就像，蛋酒，它不适合每个人，但喜欢它的人真的很喜欢它，他们是我那种人。就像，这就是整个信息。然后雪儿作为老板出场。是的，这真的很有趣。这很甜。什么是，带我们了解一下关于离开的想法，以及，以及，以及
approach to that, the decision to that, what the next five to ten years of your life looks like
if you could program it and, you know, do you allow yourself to kind of make plans and strategize a bit?
Kind of. I don't know. I feel like I can't plan around like trade wins. I feel like things are just
uncertain. Oh, that is a great way to put it. Yeah. You know? I love that expression. Yeah, that's really good. I've
never heard that before that's a fucking great way to but to strangle the metaphor you do
got to put the boat in the water and and point it point at one direction you know you didn't
strangle it you sunk it you're not where where where what island would you like to arrive
yeah yeah um you know like do you want to do do you want to do uh do you want to do you want to do
那种方法，那个决定，如果你能规划的话，你未来五到十年的生活是什么样的，你知道，你允许自己制定计划和策略吗？有点。我不知道。我觉得我无法围绕贸易风来规划。我觉得事情就是不确定。哦，那是个很好的说法。是的。你知道吗？我喜欢那个表达。是的，那真的很好。我以前从未听过，那是个他妈的伟大的方式，但为了扼杀这个隐喻，你确实得把船放进水里，然后指向一个方向，你知道，你没有扼杀它，你把它弄沉了，你不想，你想到达哪个岛，是的，是的，嗯，你知道，就像你想做，你想做，呃，你想做，你想做
do you want to do just purely comedy would you like to get into drama do you want to do more
acting more performing more what it where where is your
where are you getting pulled right now?
All of it.
I honestly, I'm sure you guys feel the same way.
Podcasting was never on the, was never on the menu,
but it's taken up a lot of space in a good way.
I would love all of that.
你想做纯粹的喜剧吗？你想进入戏剧吗？你想做更多的表演，更多的演出，更多什么，你在哪里，你现在被什么吸引？所有这些。老实说，我相信你们也有同样的感觉。播客从来不在菜单上，但它以一种好的方式占据了很多空间。我想要所有这些。
I think just to go back to like the trade wins thing,
it's like I don't, I'm honestly like thinking about
where comedy lives right now.
It's like, I feel like even,
at the Emmys, it feels like it's
relegated to this place, even though
I think comedy shows have this
extra thing they have to do where
我想回到贸易风的事情上，就像我不，我老实说是在思考喜剧现在处于什么位置。就像，我觉得即使在艾美奖上，它似乎也被降级到了这个位置，尽管我认为喜剧节目有它们必须做的额外事情，那就是
it has to present something optimistic
about the world. It's really
hard to do that right now, I think.
You know, it's like, I don't know,
I was just watching stuff,
I'm watching comedies and watching dramas sort of an
equal measure, and I'm like, the dramas are amazing,
I love the dramas, but I think the comedies have
它必须呈现出关于世界的一些乐观的东西。我认为现在很难做到这一点。你知道，就像，我不知道，我只是在看东西，我在看喜剧和看戏剧，程度相当，我就想，戏剧太棒了，我喜欢戏剧，但我认为喜剧有
this extra thing to do where it's supposed to reflect
something back at you and also
be like a nice
a thing that makes you feel good.
Yeah.
Well, first of all, there's a lot of,
it seems to sort of this trend
of a lot of pieces, material
额外的事情要做，它应该向你反射一些东西，同时也像是一个让你感觉良好的好东西。是的。好吧，首先，似乎有很多这种趋势，很多作品、材料
that's not necessarily comedy
that gets kind of,
you know, grouped in
under that umbrella.
And I don't know how much comedy you do watch.
I find that these days,
I don't watch a lot of comedy.
I don't know if you guys do.
不一定是喜剧，被归入那个伞下。我不知道你看多少喜剧。我发现这些天，我不看很多喜剧。我不知道你们看不看。
I really just don't.
I don't know if I'm missing it
or it's just not the thing for, I don't know,
you can probably tell by how boring I am.
No.
Yeah, there's different,
seems like there's different reasons why comedy is,
is not a big thing as a big thing as it used to be.
我真的只是不看。我不知道我是不是错过了它，或者它只是不适合，我不知道，你可能从我有多无聊就能看出来。不。是的，有不同的，似乎有不同的原因导致喜剧不像过去那么重要了。
It's scripted, you mean, like, in that way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's up for debate,
but we need it now more than ever.
What are the great, what are the great,
I'm asking all of you,
what are the kind of the great scripted comedy
things that are out there right now
yeah that you would watch the comeback
你是说剧本，就像，那样？是的，是的，是的，这有待商榷，但我们现在比以往任何时候都更需要它。什么是伟大的，什么是伟大的剧本喜剧，现在外面有什么，是的，你会看的，《归来记》
yeah yeah that's pretty funny yeah
that's bad I mean I love
oh god yeah she's hilarious
come back but even that
even that's a little bit like
bleak like it's like oh
this is this season's about AI
and it's about how like the writers
是的，是的，那很有趣，是的，那很糟糕，我是说我喜欢，哦天哪，是的，她太搞笑了，《归来记》，但即使是那样，也有点像凄凉，就像，哦，这一季是关于人工智能的，是关于编剧
rooms have like two people in them
and it's like whoa shit
like this is this is different than it was
10 years ago when the last season was on
it's like it just it has these weird
it just has this weird
has this weird mirror that, like, is sad to look at.
And that's what's, that's what's horror.
房间里只有两个人，就像，哇，该死，这和10年前上一季播出时不同了，它就像，它有这些奇怪的，它只是有这个奇怪的，有这个奇怪的镜子，看起来很悲伤。这就是恐怖所在。
Right, right, right.
What about, I like talking about this, your dating life, because you said.
I'm bringing this down, so, the vibes are so bad.
No, I like it.
No, what are you talking about?
I love it.
No, you're really making me think, Bonn.
Because, Sean, before we get into the dating life, you're really making me think about
对，对，对。关于，我喜欢谈论这个，你的约会生活，因为你说。我把气氛搞得这么低，所以，氛围太糟糕了。不，我喜欢它。不，你在说什么？我喜欢它。不，你真的让我思考，鲍恩。因为，肖恩，在我们进入约会生活之前，你真的让我思考
that idea that, like, and we want to get into your dating life in, and we actually, we have
some graphs.
And we also, your mom sent us some printout, we printed out some stuff.
Some charts.
some chats about some of your options some of the female options but willie you know but you but in a
recent esquire but i read your esquire interview the what i've learned piece when you were reflecting
you said about work you said you this is you saying it you said you feel like you've hit critical
mass where you did too much too soon or something like that and and and you wanted to slow down and
那个想法，就像，我们想进入你的约会生活，而且我们实际上有一些图表。而且你妈妈给我们发了一些打印件，我们打印了一些东西。一些图表。一些关于你的一些选择，一些女性选择的聊天记录，但威利，你知道，但你，但在最近的《时尚先生》采访中，我读了你的《时尚先生》采访，那个“我学到了什么”的文章，当你反思时，你说关于工作，你说你，这是你说的，你说你觉得你达到了临界质量，你做得太多太快了，或者类似的事情，而且你想慢下来，
focus on quieter work i i get that but just know that i don't feel there's millions of people that
don't feel that way about you.
Yeah, I'd take a lot more from you.
There's so much more, you know.
Yeah, for real.
Careful.
Drench me.
Hang on, Jay, your mic went out for a second.
专注于更安静的工作，我明白，但要知道，我不觉得，有数百万人对你不是那种感觉。是的，我会从你那里得到更多。还有更多，你知道。是的，真的。小心。把我淋湿。等等，杰伊，你的麦克风断了一秒。
What was that?
Just so we can get it, guys, quiet.
Let's get it clean.
Soak me.
Oh, my God.
Jason.
I gotta say, Jason showing up to S&L was always, like, everyone was sort of straightened and
be like, oh, I'm, Jason and I had a really nice, intimate conversation.
那是什么？为了让我们能录到，伙计们，安静。让我们把它弄干净。浸透我。天哪。杰森。我得说，杰森出现在SNL总是，就像，每个人都挺直了腰板，就像，哦，我，杰森和我进行了一次非常好的、亲密的谈话。
And it was like, everyone's like, I think he's flirting with me.
It was Jason's a charmer.
I like to get up nice and close.
That place, I love that place so much.
I just watched that Lauren documentary.
It was really cool.
I love it.
I haven't seen it yet.
就像，每个人都说，我想他在跟我调情。杰森是个迷人的人。我喜欢靠得近一点。那个地方，我太喜欢那个地方了。我刚看了那个劳恩的纪录片。真的很酷。我喜欢它。我还没看过。
I'm telling it.
So, Bowen, because I've read this too, and I want you to only want what you want,
but that you said it's impossible to date during SNL,
and where you would go on a couple of days
and then just vanished?
Like, what's going on?
I would vanish.
No, you would vanish.
我正在说。所以，鲍恩，因为我也读过这个，我希望你只想要你想要的，但你说在SNL期间约会是不可能的，你会去约会几次然后就消失了？就像，发生了什么？我会消失。不，你会消失。
I put that on me.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's a self-call in.
Like, I just, I would get swept up in the show and the work.
And, like, it's just so hard to, like,
put any stake in your own life, it felt like.
But I mean, that's not to say that it's impossible to do.
Now, now things are fine.
我把那归咎于自己。哦，好的。是的，这是自我召唤。就像，我只是，我会沉浸在节目和工作中。而且，就像，感觉很难在自己的生活中投入任何赌注。但我的意思是，这并不是说这是不可能做到的。现在，现在事情很好。
Like, things are normal.
I'm, like, still, still, like,
unlearning so many things in a way that I am grateful for and I also mourn how my life used to be.
Like, I do miss it so much.
I've been getting dinners and lunches with people on the breaks and who are still there.
And I'm like, oh, it's nice.
And I have to say this because people are listening.
It's okay to be single.
就像，事情很正常。我，就像，仍然，仍然，就像，在以一种我感激的方式取消学习很多东西，我也哀悼我的生活曾经的样子。就像，我真的很怀念它。我在休息时和还在那里的人一起吃晚餐和午餐。然后我就想，哦，这很好。我必须说这个，因为人们在听。单身是可以的。
Why are you saying it like that?
Why are you looking at me?
You know what?
I've never heard of.
And again, this is a guy that lives in a cave.
Oh boy, this list is long.
This list is fucking long
of stuff that you've never heard of.
你为什么那样说？你为什么看着我？你知道吗？我从来没听说过。而且，这是一个住在洞穴里的家伙。哦，男孩，这个名单很长。这个名单他妈的长，都是你从来没听说过的事情。
It's not common to hear about Saturday Night Live hookups
and couples with the cast, right?
I mean...
Or writers or whatever.
I don't think it's a gay thing.
No, in general.
Just in general.
听说《周六夜现场》的勾搭和演员之间的情侣并不常见，对吧？我是说……或者编剧什么的。我不认为这是同性恋的事情。我不认为这是同性恋的事情。不，总的来说。只是总的来说。
Like, you know, people who go to school together,
like, that's all you have
or just your classmates is sort of like,
you know, I went out with him last year and this year.
Like, you don't hear about that on SNL,
and you'd think that you would just based on schedule.
Like you don't have a chance to meet anybody else.
Really?
就像，你知道，一起上学的人，就像，这就是你所拥有的，或者只是你的同学，就像，你知道，我去年和他约会，今年又约会。就像，你在SNL没听说过那个，你会认为你会，仅仅基于时间表。就像你没有机会遇见其他人。真的吗？
You guys are in there all the time.
We're in there all the time.
Oh, but I thought you were talking about Jason, like,
intra-S-N-L hookups.
Within SNL people are having them.
Yeah, I mean, castmates dating one another
or a writer with a castmate or writers and writers,
or you don't, right?
你们一直都在那里。我们一直都在那里。哦，但我以为你在说杰森，就像，SNL内部的勾搭。在SNL内部，人们确实有。是的，我是说，演员之间约会，或者编剧和演员约会，或者编剧和编剧，或者你没有，对吧？
I know.
And you think that you would.
You're right.
I just wasn't, yeah, I didn't really encounter that,
but I don't feel like I missed out.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I don't know.
I love that your Instagram handle is at Faye Dunaway.
我知道。你会认为你会。你是对的。我只是没有，是的，我没有真正遇到过，但我不觉得我错过了什么。是的，是的。不，我不知道。我喜欢你的Instagram账号是@FayeDunaway。
That's your name on Instagram.
I didn't know that until recently.
I laughed out loud at that.
First of all, I can't believe it was available.
I can't either.
And I'm holding onto it for dear life.
I think she wants it bad.
How much time does your podcast take from you each week?
那是你在Instagram上的名字。我直到最近才知道。我为此大笑出声。首先，我不敢相信它竟然没被占用。我也不敢相信。我正死死地抓住它。我想她很想要它。你的播客每周占用你多少时间？
It siphons from me like six hours a week, which is not that bad.
Right.
Which is fine.
And with your other time, what's the ratio between work pursuits versus personal, you know, just taking care of yourself?
How hard are you working by?
I'm working decently at like a reasonable intensity.
I still am exhausted at the end of the day.
Sure.
它每周从我这里吸走大约六个小时，这还不算太糟。对。这很好。在你的其他时间里，工作追求与个人，你知道，只是照顾自己之间的比例是多少？你工作有多努力？我以合理的强度工作得还不错。我一天结束时仍然精疲力竭。当然。
I think I'm still kind of like my nervous system is still sort of like resetting from SNL where it just, it just knows a work is done.
Then it's time to go to bed.
There was that switch.
But you have to now self-program.
Like there, there was a schedule.
We had to be there a certain time.
But now you've got to do it all.
Are you finding your self-motivation adequate?
我想我仍然有点像我的神经系统仍然在从SNL重置，它只是，它只是知道工作完成了。然后是时候睡觉了。有那个开关。但你现在必须自我编程。就像，有一个时间表。我们必须在某个时间到达那里。但现在你必须自己做这一切。你觉得你的自我激励足够吗？
Not yet.
It's getting there.
How do you guys do it?
Well, I'm very good about when I'm working, I'm very, very disciplined.
And when I'm not working, I could not be worse at doing anything.
Yeah. Jason's one of my favorite quotes is Jason says, I want to aggressively do nothing.
Yeah. And then when I'm working, I'm an animal.
Well, actually, the truth is, and I mean this, when he's not working, he obsessively plays golf because it gives him something to do.
还没。快了。你们是怎么做到的？嗯，我工作时非常、非常自律。当我没工作时，我做任何事情都不能再糟糕了。是的。杰森最喜欢的名言之一是杰森说，我想积极地什么都不做。是的。然后当我工作时，我是一只动物。嗯，事实上，真相是，我是认真的，当他不工作时，他强迫性地打高尔夫球，因为它给了他事情做。
Yes. That's super challenging. So he plays it five, six days a week.
Yeah. And then he'll say to me like, hey, do you want to play tomorrow? I'm like, no. And he's like, I've got like one thing, but I can't do it all the time. Like he has to do it.
because he needs that.
I have addiction issues, Bowen.
I'm much better.
I find I'm much better when I'm not working at being able to just kind of chill.
Like I did my little stuff this morning and then kind of like go to the gym and kind of
I find it like easy.
是的。那非常有挑战性。所以他每周打五、六天。是的。然后他会对我像，嘿，你想明天打吗？我说，不。他说，我有一件事，但我不能一直做。就像他必须做。因为他需要那个。我有成瘾问题，鲍恩。我好多了。我发现当我不工作时，我能更好地放松。就像我今天早上做了我的小事，然后去健身房，我发现这很容易。
You watch some soccer, take a nap.
Those are just saggy days though, right?
Where you're like, it doesn't matter if you wake up at 8 a.m. or 11.30 a.m.
Like those days are like, I feel like I'm being irresponsible to another day of life.
Oh, I'm still up at 6.
I'm still up at 6 a.m. every day.
Right.
But, you know.
你看一些足球，小睡一会儿。那些只是下垂的日子，对吧？就像，你早上8点还是11点半醒来并不重要。就像那些日子，我觉得我对生活的另一天不负责任。哦，我仍然每天早上6点起床。仍然每天早上6点起床。对。但是，你知道。
Good for you.
get the kids to school, all that kind of stuff.
You have to do.
Kids give you that, too.
You know.
Sean's on a strict chocolate cake schedule.
That I do not stray from.
You never stray from.
为你高兴。送孩子们上学，所有那些事情。你必须做。孩子们也给你那个。你知道。肖恩有一个严格的巧克力蛋糕时间表。我从不偏离那个。你从不偏离。
That's got a mixing bowl by 10.30.
Sean, really quick, what did you have for breakfast today?
I had blood work done so I couldn't eat.
But then when I came home, I had...
Oh, no.
Now you were angry.
I had a peanut butter sandwich.
Sure.
10点半就有搅拌碗了。肖恩，快速问一下，你今天早餐吃了什么？我做了验血，所以我不能吃。但当我回家时，我吃了……哦，不。现在你生气了。我吃了一个花生酱三明治。当然。
This is a glass of milk potato chips.
Yeah, yeah.
Before 11 a.m. that was a peanut butter sandwich?
Yeah, yep, at 10.30.
There's no bad time for it.
Not at all.
There's always a good time for peanut butter sandwich.
So Las Coulteristas, which is huge,
这是一杯牛奶，薯片。是的，是的。上午11点前那是花生酱三明治？是的，是的，在10点半。吃它没有坏时间。一点也不。吃花生酱三明治总是有好时间。所以Las Coulteristas，这非常大，
just hit 10 years.
Amazing.
Wow, yeah.
It's great.
Congratulations.
Yeah, that's huge.
It's really cool.
刚刚满10年。太棒了。哇，是的。哇，是的。这很棒。恭喜。是的，那太大了。真的很酷。
What year are you guys on?
Six.
Half that.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're about to hit six.
And then you have Cat in the Hat coming out November 6th with Warner Brothers, which is amazing.
I love that.
你们在第几年？六年。一半。是的。是的，我们快满六年了。是的。然后你有《戴帽子的猫》在11月6日与华纳兄弟一起上映，这太棒了。我喜欢那个。
Bill Hater.
It's amazing.
Did you see it yet?
No.
I love it.
I forgot that I'm in it.
I think that's going to be huge.
And then the last thing I want to do with you, which is such a great thing you do on your podcast.
比尔·哈德。太棒了。你看了吗？不。我喜欢它。我忘了我在里面。我想那会很火。然后我想和你做的最后一件事，这是你在播客上做的很棒的事情。
It's called.
Oh, what is it called?
I don't think so, honey.
Good Sean.
Which is similar to who's that guy that Jason you brought on, the taxi cab guy who films
Oh, the subway takes good?
The subway?
它叫。哦，它叫什么？我不这么认为，亲爱的。我不这么认为，亲爱的。好肖恩。这类似于杰森你带来的那个家伙，那个出租车司机，他拍摄，哦，地铁，拍得很好？地铁？
Oh, Karim.
Kareem.
It's a similar thing to what Kareem does,
which is you have a thing.
I don't want to put you on the spot if you don't have one.
But do you have a...
I'm sure I do.
I've got one.
哦，卡里姆。卡里姆。这和卡里姆做的事情类似，就是你有一件事。如果你没有，我不想让你难堪。但你有一个……我相信我有。我有一个。
Or your favorite one?
I've got one.
Okay, what is it?
I don't think so honey.
Outdoor furniture.
It's a scam.
It is only meant to be dirtied.
Your cushions are flying all around.
或者你最喜欢的一个？我有一个。好的，它是什么？我不这么认为，亲爱的。户外家具。这是一个骗局。它注定只能被弄脏。你的垫子到处乱飞。
You've got to like bring down the umbrella.
The rugs get dirty.
There's no maintenance on outdoor furniture,
but we feel compelled.
It is compulsory that we buy it to fill out our outdoor spaces,
and yet it never aesthetically looks pleasing.
It's a terrible, terrible cycle.
It's almost Faustian.
你得把伞收下来。地毯变脏了。户外家具没有维护，但我们感到被迫。我们必须买它来填满我们的户外空间是强制性的，然而它在美学上看起来从来都不令人愉悦。这是一个可怕的、可怕的循环。它几乎是浮士德式的。
I don't know how, but it's like we give up something,
we give up our...
The indignation of outdoor furniture is terrible.
And I know this is a very, like, champagne problem-y thing to have,
but it's just awful.
We have to cover it when it's raining.
It should give you a power washer with it.
Oh, I love it.
我不知道怎么回事，但就像我们放弃了一些东西，我们放弃了我们的……户外家具的愤慨太可怕了。我知道这是一个非常像“香槟问题”的事情，但这太糟糕了。下雨时我们必须盖住它。它应该给你一个高压清洗机。哦，我喜欢它。
That's a great take.
Mine is, I just thought of this,
knowing you were coming on
because it just happened to me yesterday,
is pulling up to a parking spot
where there's a meter,
or trying to find a parking spot,
somebody comes out,
那是个很棒的观点。我的是，我刚想到这个，知道你要来，因为它昨天刚发生在我身上，就是开到一个有停车表的停车位，或者试图找一个停车位，有人出来，
they get in their car,
so you put your clicker on
because they're about to pull out
and they never pull out.
They're on their phone.
They take 20 minutes.
This is their time.
Yeah.
他们上了车，所以你打开了转向灯，因为他们正要开出来，但他们从来没开出来。他们在打电话。他们花了20分钟。这是他们的时间。是的。
I don't think so, honey.
Yeah, I don't think so many.
I don't think so many.
But you know what I think,
Boen Yang, you are brilliant,
you are hilarious from the first time I saw you.
Thank you for being here today.
I love you guys.
我不这么认为，亲爱的。是的，我不这么认为，亲爱的。我不这么认为，亲爱的。但你知道我怎么想，鲍恩·杨，你太聪明了，从我第一次见到你开始你就太搞笑了。谢谢你今天来到这里。我爱你们。
You're a treasure.
You're not just a national treasure.
It turns out you're an international treasure of many countries.
You hot that.
Continentally North America.
The Commonwealth's.
Commonwealth.
Thank you for being here, Bowen.
你真是个宝藏。你不仅是国宝，事实证明你还是多个国家的国际宝藏。你很抢手。在北美大陆，在英联邦。英联邦。谢谢你来到这里，博文。
Thank you, man.
Thanks, guys.
And thanks, Bowen.
Yeah, I love it.
Nice going.
I know Jason hates it.
He hates an afternoon record.
I do.
谢谢你，伙计。谢谢大家。也谢谢你，博文。是的，我很喜欢。干得好。我知道杰森讨厌下午录音。我确实讨厌。
Oh, my God.
You're so right.
This is staying in.
You made it worse it, though.
Keep it in.
made it worth it.
You've changed my attitude about it.
天哪。你说得太对了。你说得太对了。这段要保留。不过你让它变得值得了。保留下来。让它变得值得。你改变了我对这件事的态度。
They can all be like Bowen-Yang records.
Let's do it then.
That was really fun.
Thanks, Bowen.
Thanks, boys.
All right.
Thanks, buddy.
它们都可以像博文·杨的录音一样。那我们就这么做吧。这真的很有趣。谢谢，博文。谢谢，博文。谢谢，伙计们。好的。谢谢，伙计。
Bye.
See, have a good week.
Have a great rest of the day.
Bye.
Oh, great.
I like him.
I like him a lot.
I want to be his friend.
再见。看，祝你这周过得愉快。祝你今天余下的时间过得愉快。再见。哦，太棒了。我喜欢他。我非常喜欢他。我想成为他的朋友。
I know.
I think we are his friend.
He's really funny.
Do you think he has any openings for friends?
I think so.
I think he does.
I would underperform.
I'm a terrible friend.
我知道。我想我们已经是他的朋友了。他真的很有趣。你觉得他还有交友名额吗？我想有的。我想他有的。我会表现得很差劲。我是一个糟糕的朋友。
Let's have dinner with him.
Yeah, he's one of those people that super intelligent and super funny.
And I think the two often go hand in hand.
Not in my case, but yeah.
Yeah.
And then also, I think it's...
Oh, sorry, do you want to push back on that?
我们和他一起吃顿饭吧。是的，他是那种超级聪明又超级有趣的人。我觉得这两者通常是相辅相成的。虽然我不属于这种情况，但确实如此。是的。是的。还有，我觉得……哦，抱歉，你想反驳这一点吗？
Sorry.
No, I don't want to put back.
No.
I need to get better about going out to dinner, don't I?
In order to be just a halfway decent friend, I need to actually get out of the house.
You go, though, sometimes.
I mean, but I don't even take your phone calls.
I know.
抱歉。不，我不想反驳。不。我需要改进一下出去吃饭的习惯，对吧？为了做一个还算凑合的朋友，我确实需要走出家门。不过你有时还是会出去的。我是说，但我甚至不接你的电话。我知道。
This is true.
You guys tried to FaceTime.
the other day and I just wouldn't have it.
You know what happened today?
It was you and Josh, Willie.
No, you know what happened today is the three of us
were on a texting chain and then I stopped
这是真的。这是真的。你们前几天试着跟我视频通话，但我就是不接。你知道今天发生了什么吗？是你和乔什，威利。不，你知道今天发生了什么，是我们三个人在一个短信群里，然后我退出了
because I know you don't like to get pinged, contrary.
Well, just build the paragraph and send that.
I don't need 17 cents.
But sometimes you need a conversation to go back and forth.
So we're going back and forth with the thing we were all talking about.
And Sean's like, I feel bad because I feel like Jason
doesn't want to get annoyed.
So I took you off and I just went to me and well.
因为我知道你不喜欢被打扰，相反。好吧，只要把段落写好发过来就行。我不需要17条零碎的信息。但有时你需要来回交流。所以我们正在就大家都在谈论的事情进行来回交流。肖恩说，我感到很抱歉，因为我觉得杰森不想被打扰。所以我把你移出了群聊，只剩下我和威利。
We have to manage Gramps.
Really?
Yeah, because he has a breaking point.
What about, I'll just leave the conversation.
I'll just hit that button if it gets too much.
Well, what would you say?
Jason got so mad at me because he kept leaving Nurtle
when we were doing it a few years ago
我们得照顾好老爷爷。真的吗？是的，因为他有崩溃的临界点。那如果我直接退出对话呢？如果受不了了，我就按那个按钮。好吧，你会说什么？杰森因为几年前我们做那个节目时他一直退出群聊而对我非常生气
because he didn't want the full back and forth.
And then I kept adding him back.
He's like, fuck off.
It's like the fish that wiggles off the hook
and you keep gaffing it and pulling it into the boat.
It was so funny.
I'd be like, guys, watch this.
And then I'd add him into the conversation.
因为他不想进行那种来回的交流。然后我一直把他加回去。他就像是说，滚开。就像那条从钩子上挣脱的鱼，你不断地用鱼叉把它钩住拉回船上。这太搞笑了。我会说，伙计们，看这个。然后我就把他加回对话中。
That is so funny.
Jason, what would you say if you left the conversation?
I would say bye.
Bye.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf.
Smartless.
那太搞笑了。杰森，如果你退出了对话，你会说什么？我会说再见。再见。Smartless是由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆朱夫百分之百有机且手工制作的。Smartless。